hey what's up guys dopaziola here i just
wanted to take a moment to
introduce one of our new sponsors so
introducing to the podcast this is tushy
hellotushy.com this is a bidet system
for your home and i'm about to tell you
exactly why you need one all right guys
let's be honest toilet paper works but
not always sometimes your ass is still
dirty don't lie it happens to all of us
yes i understand that the day seemed
kind of weird because it is water going
to
directly up your ass but it's way
[ __ ] cleaner also think about this
during the pandemic when everybody was
out there searching for toilet paper
don't you wish you were at home with
your own bidet from tushy instead of
fighting over toilet paper
so join the club and go to
hellotushy.com and don't be a stinky ass
fool
[Music]
the water
if you follow our podcast you already
know the second we got this sponsorship
we're gonna do a wild ass commercial
that is what i thought of when i was
falling asleep the other night i thought
you know what would be funny me [ __ ]
so introducing one of our new sponsors
guys this is tushy tushyhellotushi.com
this is a bidet this is the [ __ ] that
used to see as a kid on tv but those
rich ass [ __ ] got bidets
now you don't got to be a rich ass
[ __ ] to have a bidet so let me
blow your mind on the product that will
blow into your [ __ ] you like that one
best sponsorship ever
i didn't realize how dirty it was until
i read some of the talking points and
went
you're [ __ ] right you step in dog
[ __ ] outside don't you wash it off i
have never seen anybody just wipe it off
with toilet paper and just keep going
that's when i realized like whoa
i'm walking around with a dirty ass
something else that blew my mind is your
ass clean enough to sit on your sheet
and get up and you're like yeah there's
definitely no [ __ ] on the bed is your
bear [ __ ] trustworthy enough
sit on your mother-in-law's couch
so i just installed this it's not hard
and i don't like directions there's no
electricity hookup there's no plumbing
required you just put it on your toilet
strap it on hook it to your water you're
done so guys make sure you get yourself
a tissue at www.hellotushy.com
forward slash dope that's ten percent
off hello tushy not tushy
hellotushy.com
not just tushy.com just leave it at that
just look at hellotushi trust me guys
it's cleaner you don't have to spend
money on as much toilet paper honestly
why don't more people have them i don't
know as we say all the time thank you
for supporting the brands that support
us if you do end up buying one of these
tag us at dope as usual podcast on
instagram or tag hellotushy we'll try to
see them all repost you guys show the
love thank you guys for supporting us
here at the dopes usual podcast we can
guarantee that all of our fans [ __ ]
are spotless
[Music]
i think that's about it
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]
hey what's up everybody dopeziola here
thomas whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast i am here with marty
yo yo what's up marty um guys let's get
off uh right into this podcast let's get
into this episode that is the first time
i think i didn't
mess up
just talking about the intro usually i
go hey can you uh
can you start it over again
so all right episode 28 i finally nailed
it okay here we go and i didn't even do
the intro we're here to talk about life
drugs accomplishments problems and
everything in between
there we go one take all right all right
guys uh this episode 28 it is friday
night usually we film on tuesday but we
uh
for the first time had a guest
kind of cancelled so
it's all good okay well it's all right
well we'll uh
we'll get it going just the scheduling
just did not work man it just didn't
work it didn't work out but uh here we
go guys episode 28.
if you tuned in last week thank you so
much that was the longest episode we
ever did oh no that's the longest solo
episode we've ever done yeah right yeah
yeah because you're
went like four four hours but that was
me talking [ __ ] to my mom so uh
yeah guys thank you so much for for
watching for hanging out
we uh kind of get right into this first
topic and the first topic is we just got
approved for our 100 000 subscriber
plaque
holy [ __ ] youtube's actually like yeah
good job i can't believe it i can't
believe they said it it took what three
weeks to approve us
usually takes 48 hours we did it though
i thought their i thought they were
[ __ ] toying i thought they were
[ __ ] with us too man i really did
think like we'll get back to you um it's
taking longer than expected we'll get
back to you what's the email you use to
sign up like bro what are you looking
for
you're just waiting for us to well you
know [ __ ] you they were trying to i
think they were trying to find any
reason but
thanks youtube we appreciate that shout
out thank you he's trying to be like
everybody else we just want to be like
the regular kids man all right we just
want to get
the same things everybody else does when
they hit those milestones so for people
that follow youtube that's a
getting the plaque is awesome i i mean
having any platform say
no you're okay you could stay here
that's what i'm like because i get to
lead it off everything i've never got a
plaque for all the dopesy old [ __ ] so
it's weird to see it's weird for it to
happen but it's more significant because
everything we've gone through
and because we set out to be like we're
going to make something they can't [ __ ]
with
this is unfuck with a ball
that was the whole goal behind the
[ __ ] podcast because we already have
to treat your [ __ ] so different like on
dopaziola.com for instance we have to
have a whole backup copy of the video
loaded up on the site in case the
channel comes down we've been knowing
that and vin meal kicked us off yeah
that was some extra [ __ ]
i've ever heard of that
yeah not unless you're on some [ __ ]
far right conspiracy theory [ __ ] but
anyway it's all good we got that [ __ ]
all worked out
and uh we're in the good graces of
youtube here so we're just you know
thanks
youtube they demonetized the last
episode even though all we did talk
about our families and [ __ ] last episode
was so special youtube get your [ __ ]
[ __ ] together for that one i know we're
on the 10 minute nights guy o'clock but
god damn how many
what other podcast in recent history has
generated that type of like community
around like
just people all tapping into the same
vibe like that yeah
but it's all good you guys make it
happen thank you very much the clips
channel is booming
we've uploaded like 25 clips in the past
week
so go watch it all right clips channel
is the highlight reel of this if you
don't have the attention span to watch
the entire channel just go to dope as yo
dope's usual podcast clips
same [ __ ] it's just it's just the
highlight reel man i was going through
some of them the other day they're
ridiculous they're ridiculous and we're
still trying to keep them super clean
yes it could be our best possible like
we're trying to not like
selling crack
or something crazy even though
it might have to do with selling crack
yeah yeah i don't know
but uh it's it's
it's cool clips channel guys thank you
so much for watching thank you for
supporting
this episode you know how many times i
said let's keep it an hour and a half
today we're going to keep it an hour and
a half because we have to edit this
[ __ ] in one day
we usually edit it in five yeah
so we're gonna we're gonna keep it an
hour and a half i have my list
tight last week was the first time we
never did any notes
yeah look what happened and the last
story time i did no notes didn't write
[ __ ] just went you know what let's go
because usually i had to go don't forget
to talk about this don't forget because
i'll be caught up in a story
and completely forget to talk about my
friend that got arrested at the same
time or
something crazy
yeah i always forget so i want to go
back and watch my first episodes i'm
like
bro there was like 15 more minutes of
[ __ ] i forgot to talk about
like i forgot about it i just forgot to
talk about it or there'd be a lot of
times where i you know you notice how i
mumble and talk my words bleed in
together sometimes i can't make that cut
so i'll leave the whole topic out
because i don't want to be like and
just jump ship on the whole thought yeah
i cut off whole i did it today
i gotta
gotta stop rolling my [ __ ]
words together but that's how i talk so
uh
there's no possible way we're at ten
minutes
no no okay [ __ ] i just wanna smoke that
choice so bad
okay today for the first time one of the
first times in my life i fell asleep for
like an hour and a half in the middle of
the day so now i woke up with like a
whole new day it's all weird
so here we go guys this episode like i
said we're keeping it tight we're gonna
we are going to do an hour and a half
today this almost feels like a recap
quick get together between that last
epic episode and the next run of gusts
that we're about to go on let's let's uh
you know what i'm gonna switch my notes
around let's talk about the guess right
now instead of the end
next week we film
goblin aircon we're gonna have our first
ever two guest setup special event it
might be the last episode on the set
right i hope maybe possibly we're moving
sets but it's gonna look the same so you
won't know it's just gonna be not hot
and dusty for us so um
next week eric khan and goblin same
episode
i'm still planning i'm still planning it
out because goblin's a story machine
and i want to hear some more [ __ ] so um
i'm trying to figure it out like well
introdu like mix our three personalities
together it's gonna be a feat
it's a little hard to do i don't know
i'm excited for it it's gonna just go
i'm excited like uh this is the weed
tube episode basically like this is the
the youtubers of weed you know what i
mean like this is not rushmore this is
the one man i'm excited
um so we have goblin eric khan for
everyone out there wondering and then
right after that we locked in
brad right after that we got brian
callan uh marty's been working with
brian callen for i don't know how many
years 50 50
so yeah
uh we got brian callum coming in for
those who don't know brian county he's a
comedian i know him as cabana boy
because i've been watching mad tv since
i was born
uh i just know it's a cabana boy
i'm not gonna even talk about it it's
cabana boy the [ __ ] he's
you you know exactly is you've seen
hangover you know who the guy is he's a
funny [ __ ] before i started
working with marty assange with the
comedy store i was like yo
this guy's funny as [ __ ] so i'm excited
about that so goblin aircon then right
after that brian callan
then we're gonna get into some
[ __ ] stories because the next
guest after that is freeway rick ross
and if you don't know who freeway mcross
is he's the real rick ross the rick ross
rapper stole his name from this guy
because he thought he wasn't getting out
of jail out of prison yeah he thought he
was staying so this guy is
pretty much america's biggest coke
dealer
right he was doing he was working with
what's the contra contra right i don't
want to butcher his story yeah i don't
want to [ __ ] it up but i know he was
running so many bricks
he got life
all right so we're like a real deal drug
trapping ass [ __ ] from l.a i
posted a picture with him um the other
day coincidentally just like a throwback
picture talking about a story letting
people know hey go listen to his
episodes on rogan because they're epic
and
like just not to give away in the story
but even in the caption i wrote he
couldn't read going into prison he got a
life sentence
involving corrupt parts of the
government that was trying to put him
down forever he had a life sentence he
couldn't read taught himself to read in
prison found a loophole got himself out
of his life sentence
people in the government all this other
[ __ ] it all got exposed whatever
whatever gets out of jail
this fool rick ross the rapper has
stolen his identity
and his likeness and his name and is out
there the biggest crack cocaine rapper
out there
and then gets sued and acts like he
doesn't know who rick rocks is
so it's this crazy ass story and not to
mention he's all deep in the weed world
and all this [ __ ] now so it's great he's
out he's got a brand which is the best
thing he could have [ __ ] did yeah the
best thing he could do was come out and
go legit
yeah i mean [ __ ] what a story yeah oh my
god i'm barely yeah i didn't even want
to touch you
this is not even a spoiler alert though
way more beyond there's so much i mean
i've watched a part of the documentary
in
holy [ __ ] yeah he is the movie yeah he
is a move he's a movie bro
wow and [ __ ]
i always wanted to talk because one of
my favorite movies growing up was blow i
loved i love that's why i really want to
start selling packs the reason i took
the reason i took those zips on the
airplane because whenever he was talking
about the false bottoms and oh the
cocaine case and uh old habit's hard to
break he's talking about the underwear
i'm like ah
i'm pretty sure i can get away with some
weed and that's why i took the weed on
the plane because i'm like you know what
george young can get away with this what
a dumb ass kid
and uh
i met the real guy like
i was five years ago i was in the
cannabis cup and i was walking by the
bathroom and i see this guy's posted up
i'm like
that's [ __ ] george young the real
george young and it really was him he
got out and started writing books and
doing cannabis community stuff and he
just recently passed away a couple
months ago
maybe even a month ago he just passed
away
yeah my timeline's probably [ __ ] it
was a year ago and [ __ ] but yeah he just
passed away but i remember i looked down
like
thanks
thank you because you started this
you got me into like you know what
pretty sure i can go stash all this weed
at school
i'm pretty sure i can get away i think i
can get this 10-pound i think i can make
this straight across that line
maybe maybe it was bad but i used to
watch it every day
every day and ram jam black betty by ram
jam was my favorite song at the time
because
when he's walking through the airport
and all white like yo this was the
coolest guy
ever bro and that's how i started
selling weed
i'm not kidding
but uh
freeway rick ross kind of reminds me
that george young except the coke route
except he got out he got himself out not
to mention he was doing this [ __ ] in
south central
south central ladies not even all in the
not even in the gang line [ __ ] just like
it's like yo that full makes money don't
[ __ ] with them that's kind of how i
looked at it but
we'll find out okay and i've met him
before he's a very nice dude like a
super
upstanding ass dude so i'm excited to
talk to him he's out there all the time
hustling his books and all this yeah his
book he's got his wii going it's in the
shops all that [ __ ] so
aircon goblin
right after that brian kelln right after
that freeway rick ross
and that is gonna lead us up until like
mid september-ish
we don't want to say anything else we'll
just tell you those next guests we
appreciate you guys when we when we
throw something out on instagram trying
to get somebody's attention we
appreciate you guys tagging them and
check because that's one of the main
ways that we can get people that are
kind of out of our reach
or people that would be great guests but
we don't have the ability to just get at
them
you know because a lot of people ask
like why don't you just get this guy
like why don't you just get this guy
help me
yeah please i don't mean he'll help me
man he's got to remember guys we're uh a
lot of people like you're the biggest
weed guy like
nobody gives a [ __ ] about that
you gotta remember they see me they see
the way i talk talk see all the packs
all the crazy [ __ ] go
i don't know if i want to go to that
warehouse i don't know if i can yeah i
don't know if i want to be in there
three hour conversation with us for
that that too like are you ready are you
ready to talk don't be honest
just don't come
it's nerve-racking for the average
person yeah i'll never badger a
[ __ ] or anything like that but
there are some things because it's not
like we don't pay guests we don't they
have to come because they want to be on
their own i want to talk to the fans and
[ __ ] so
it's interesting it doesn't hurt that
our other channel is the biggest one in
the world it doesn't hurt
yeah so it does help like the weed area
but uh we're not just we people
as you can see we've had a lot of guests
on that aren't we people at all
something didn't even [ __ ] smoke
i would venture to say a lot of people
that found the podcast without knowing
who dopiola was like
i had a lot of those messages wouldn't
bring up weed as the first thing when
they described the podcast that's what
we were going for like yeah that's what
the whole goal was i got i want this to
be the 420 podcast in any way shape or
form
mm-hmm i'm i'm good we said that at the
beginning just like how brogan did it
we'll have the weeds going to be there
but
yeah right speaking of weed what time is
it yeah it's got to be yeah it's past
yeah yeah
i smoked the little one first
all right do you have any you have your
[ __ ] ready yeah yeah yeah okay cool cool
i called you last time like you picked
up that big ass joint you drop right oh
yeah i dropped a joint under i smoked
that [ __ ] that night hell yeah oh yeah i
don't leave
leave joints on the ground
um okay cool cool so we got into that
questions i mean uh we got into the 100k
plaque thank you guys so much for that
we will show you that in the second week
i don't know how i'm going to react when
i get my plaque i might [ __ ] smack a
[ __ ]
you only live with your kids and why i'm
not just smack them off
which one you pissed me the [ __ ] off i'm
gonna be so [ __ ] excited just punch a
hole in your wall that you're leaving
there you go there you go marty got the
house we talked about it now marty's new
house is in shambles because they're
uh they're re-uh constructing remodeling
oh my god [ __ ] yeah you want to talk
about getting into some [ __ ] remodel a
full house after you just bought a house
for the first time immediately it's
awesome though i can't wait you guys
move in yeah that's a lot man i realized
like i was considering my day rates
going in there like these fools are
working
and they they're they're opting out of
the ac being on in the house too which
is interesting i don't know just
i have no [ __ ] idea they're in there
working and i'm like damn this is real
work in here
digging up these [ __ ] floors and
ripping off these covers that's what
made me work hard
seeing my dad work hard like you're
older than me bro i got to work just as
hard as you you're older than me like
i'm younger i should be on this [ __ ]
yeah that's what makes you work hard
yeah that's why nothing else makes me
phases me because i used to do 18-hour
days
manual labor so yeah yeah
this is easy
yeah and i'm about to volunteer my kids
to [ __ ] work for these fools
100
start letting them know like no no
that was five dollars for that half an
hour oh we found a note in the walls
[ __ ] i would do what did it say
so we think a rat dragged it up into the
walls because it had all these little
bite marks on it and [ __ ]
and it was like a letter from a girl to
her boyfriend
like
putting him on notice of all these bible
verses and how you shouldn't be with
prostitutes and how all this sex [ __ ]
but in the context of like
biblical
verses a whole page had it all written
out and then on some all right glad we
got that cleared up that's basically how
she wrapped it up
she said you can't have sex with hookers
and be with me
yeah
but she's quoting the bible throughout i
understand
she wrote a note
how old was that i'm trying to figure
that out because that's that sounds more
like a text
man it was a hand written this is before
text message
i could tell it was a girl's handwriting
and she's like a gel pen yeah yeah she
signed it at the bottom this is a 1996
no she signed it angela
uh parentheses ange just in case you
didn't know
just in case
the girl you're dating might not you
don't remember her name the one that
you're not hanging on with prostitutes
is schooling you up on why the lord said
that wasn't cool
her if you didn't remember i'm so glad
you
wow yeah i know i just what i know it
was [ __ ] hilarious
i've threw a note in a wall before but
it's just like hey [ __ ] just to [ __ ]
with somebody you have no idea what
happened in these walls in this room oh
[ __ ] that's scary
well i told you a couple months ago
someone sent me a letter
i tell you that like oh you you were
here when i got the letter
someone sent me a letter to my how to my
my p.o box and i went how the [ __ ] you
get my p.o box okay
i thought it was a weird fan
that wrote some weird [ __ ] because the
[ __ ] was off you guys ready
it was just quoting all these things
about mother nature and death and this
and all this [ __ ] all the letters had
been like coffee stained crumbled put
dirt so they looked old
like and deliberately
like yes and i'm reading it and i'm like
huh
why
death
who is this
why did i open this and i'm like
i'm gonna text my sister because it's
probably her and i text my sister what
are you talking about
my own [ __ ]
definitely anthrox
it was like mother earth and death and
the way she becomes this and like oh no
no
and then
like hours later my sister just starts
texting me exactly what was in the
letter oh and i'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then when i got toward the end it
goes so you sent me a letter you creep
why did you send me this
and i'm asking like so what does this
mean and then she just text me a link
from batman forever
with uma thurman and it's poison ivy
it's her speech when she goes into the
[ __ ] ball
it's her whole [ __ ] dialogue and like
[ __ ]
i didn't get the last letter she goes oh
i sent two letters and the last page was
in that one i would have understood what
she was talking about if it ended with
poison ivy but i didn't get it imagine
her speech from that movie and the last
letter was missing the last page because
it wouldn't fit the letter was stuffed
oh yeah yeah that's i got it days later
i threw it away immediately and then
she's like you didn't keep it go [ __ ] i
thought it was a weirdo why would i keep
it
just text me this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's all i can think ransom noted
don't that's what i said don't ran some
notes things to me like crazy things
people really write crazy random like uh
i manage rogan's facebook like i was
telling you people write
crazy ass random [ __ ] in like that all
the time for sure
uh god has god has called me meet me
downtown so i can all that type of
people get the [ __ ] in the comments of
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just magnified
like the
the uh entitlement people have
it's not real
you should give it to him because you
know my name is kevin yeah i've done
things
all right kevin i get people like that
at least you could do is reply to me let
me go
you're one of 50 000 messages i just saw
it
[ __ ] i was asleep
i woke up to check messages and i'm a
piece of [ __ ] at least you could reply
to me you [ __ ] i get that all the time
yeah and i always reply
eat a dick that's tough
i mean imagine when we were kids you're
sitting there i'm laying there i got my
dmx my early dmx going imagine me
sitting there feeling like i could just
write him a comment and sit there and
wait for him to be full for not
responding
what these fools had fan clubs and [ __ ]
you'd write into back in the day and
hopefully get a [ __ ] generic
wait a minute i'm not getting dick back
ever for anything you gotta remember
though it takes
for people you guys like say i wrote
adam sandler i'm like yo you didn't
answer i wrote you 12 times like bro
he's adam sandler
you imagine how many things he's got to
do imagine how many things you got to do
now imagine him
times that by 50 because you don't know
what you're dealing with
then go i can't even go to the store
without getting [ __ ] mobbed and then
go oh yeah i have kids and a wife you
don't have time to check [ __ ]
messages
okay and if you're on your phone by the
time you have your down time you're with
your wife and kids they're gonna go can
you get off your phone you're rarely
here
oh my god think about that
yeah of course i mean i feel like that's
obvious to people like no it's not
people really think that you're just
sitting there
you know what mike
[ __ ] you
no mike
charles or whatever your name is yeah
this [ __ ] having direct access to the
people that you like watching is a new
thing
it's new it's brand new that's i feel
like we're the first generation of that
that's how i built drastic graphics i
built this yeah respond to everybody
because everyone took the time to talk
and watch so i gotta take the time to
talk and watch for 500 million [ __ ]
at the times
you're unique though because nobody else
does that that's but that is why this
community is so so strong yeah i
remember fools from [ __ ] 10 years
i've explained that to celebrities and
they just give me a blank stare because
they're like well do i get paid for that
no [ __ ]
they paid for your car payment that's
why you respond
the way you just went and bought lunch
is because you have fans
yeah respond [ __ ] that's yeah part of
the job that's the j that's that is your
job yeah that is your job mm-hmm respond
what do you mean go live what do you
mean yeah
what do you mean answer comments
half these people think people are
common are [ __ ] losers like no
they're your fans
they're the community
i mean obviously
and they're going hey hey hey that hey
it's a comment yeah totally
right yeah
some people don't appreciate that some
people don't remember when they were 12
thinking maybe one day i'll have fans
i've had these pep talks with some
[ __ ] celebrities before literally
like bro let me take you back there had
to be a moment when you're sitting on
the porch with your boys and all this
seem [ __ ] impossible right the [ __ ]
are we bitching about here
thank you
when you bought a foreign car from your
fans support oh you can take a picture
with them you're cool
sick
that's how i feel like yeah i don't [ __ ]
with you anymore that's why i love shavo
so much right he's so genuine like that
he's such a cool [ __ ]
just when you meet people like that it's
like it's so rare
it's so rare that's why when i met you i
was like people might have been like
surprised i go i was working with all
these comedians and it's like no i'm
gonna i'm pushing all my chips in on
[ __ ] yola because i can tell that
this is real
this isn't some hollywood
weirdo [ __ ] it's a weirdo [ __ ] where you
know like this is real i'm willing to
i'm going to invest get myself into this
[ __ ]
yeah dude like i said i was watching uh
like the commercial i did a couple years
ago i was watching all my old [ __ ]
because i got locked out of my second
channel
i couldn't remember the password i'm
trying to read you all because i changed
it because somebody tried to break into
it one day so i like changed a couple
numbers while i was editing or while i
was filming so i went oh
i'll remember and i forgot so anyway i
went in there last night just looking at
all the
comments from a year ago responding to
people and like
it's so much change in a year like so
much
elevation and going from the commercial
and doing all the stuff starting the
second channel it's
it's crazy it's crazy how fast
everything elevated like especially with
the podcast and how it just started and
then it started up so well
and now it's just
steamrolling [ __ ] snowballing just
getting bigger and bigger and it's just
getting better
it's cool it's cool to see the change
from us just starting you know
so um
marty
100k plaque we talked about the guests
guys i'm trying to keep this hour and a
half tight
where are we at right now
about 20. good good
let's bust into this because like i said
this is going to be one of the few
solo episodes we're doing over the
course of the next month or two because
we have so many guests lined up i know
we said that last week
we also didn't expect someone to flake
so
here we go guys let's go straight into
fan questions marty we posted on our
instagram our instagram is dope as usual
podcast that's instagram it's linked in
all of the video descriptions it's in
the header of youtube everything all of
our stuff
that [ __ ] looks sick last episode when
you did your hand like that we had to
[ __ ] slide out
huh remember you're like at dope as
usual podcast
i didn't notice i was typing it it
worked yeah yeah oh i was typing damn it
in the premiere i was typing so i didn't
see it [ __ ]
here's our youtube our instagram right
here okay that's dope's usual podcast
guys we posted earlier and said if you
can ask one question on the podcast what
would it be
here we go we got some [ __ ]
questions this is coming from matthew
gilbreth
all right
all right here we go that's an awesome
name
what were the craziest likes you have
ever went
what is why am i dumb
what were the craziest lengths you ever
went to in order to get high marty can
you start that one off
oh man you're from the east coast yeah
the crazy it was a goddamn adventure
every time i went to go get weed for uh
right up until i moved here
it literally was i mean these aren't
like i like i could i'm sure sit here
and think of some crazy ass extravagant
story but it was constant just cat and
mouse getting like
the whole time going in to
because on the east coast generally at
least in my world you got to go to the
worst neighborhoods to get weed
and uh when you're a white dude that
it's just like you might as well have a
[ __ ] target yeah
yeah that's the whole thing if they see
you you're getting pulled over yeah
they're waiting they're hiding if they
see you you're getting pulled over so i
would just accept that every day we
talked about this in the first episode
yeah yeah racially profile constantly
all the time all the [ __ ] time it was
always a [ __ ] adventure
yeah yeah yeah why did you go over
because i'm white
because i'm white yo yeah [ __ ]
love it yeah sorry but
so uh constantly just getting pulled
over by the cops and having the wheat in
the car and having it just hidden just
playing it off would be some pretty
great lengths for shitty you got to
consider i'm also talking about tens and
twenty shitty weed you got your whole
[ __ ] life on the line over because
then you get arrested and now you go to
get your little [ __ ] cubicle job
and you got to explain to him
i knew
you got to go through the whole [ __ ]
thing because now you're a goddamn
criminal now it's going to be hard for
you to get a job in a city where there
is no [ __ ] jobs so that's why these
[ __ ] now i hope they feel so [ __ ]
stupid that it's becoming illegal or
it's becoming legal
every day
so every time every time was at crazy
length every yeah every single time and
i only had five six dollars out of
[ __ ] time so it was like a daily
goddamn occurrence ugh
uh yeah yeah uh all for what [ __ ] was
[ __ ] stupid they could have been uh
having my tax money in this whole
[ __ ] time well
now they do
so that was marty's answer was yes every
[ __ ] day
every time i smoked was crazy
i had i had to climb a mountain pretty
much every time
me
uh i have about five i'm gonna give you
one
one time i was with my friend scott
ducey and uh i was at my grandma grace's
house out in the country
and my dad obviously he was there but he
was tweaking i didn't like i said i
didn't know he was tweaking in the
garage while we were sneaking off smoke
bowls we were both hiding in from each
other so we can go do our own drugs
which is [ __ ] hysterical to me and um
this candy this guy named chris the guy
that used to front me sax when i talked
about john the black blackbeard's
delight that weed is from this guy chris
he's the first person to ever front me
sack i was getting fronted zips in the
10th grade from him and uh when i moved
to golden valley the other school he was
the one who went there before i moved
anyway
he lives in the cuts because he is rich
as [ __ ] his family has an estate
and in merced if your family has any
money like whoa but if your family's
like that it's like
oh [ __ ] you have a paid off truck like
you know what i'm saying like that
silverado's paid for
okay
not used
damn anyway
i went to chris's and he's like yo i
can't i'm not mobile right now i go
but you have all the cars okay it's all
good
uh okay so i said dad dad i forgot my
house key
that's what i told him for my house go
dad i forgot my house key at my friend
chris's house he goes thomas
get it tomorrow but
i i need it i was just trying to
convince my dad i needed my house key
so you could drive me and scott ducey to
chris's house
and i bought a 20 second weed
and he lives in the cuts too so it's
like if we walked it was about three
miles into the country in the night
me and scott we're both fat kids already
doing that [ __ ] right
so my dad come on come on come on he's
like no
what the [ __ ]
no i'm not driving you anywhere i
finally convinced him maybe
maybe he went to the garage and got on
one was like i need to take a drive but
i convinced his ass
we drive out there i call chris we're in
the backyard of a field turns out it was
his backyard the field
he's got a yard
and there's chris in his [ __ ]
abercrombie hoodie you know i'm like
damn this fool's just got money this is
crazy you know he's selling sacks to buy
alcohol on the weekends that bad you
don't even need this money it's crazy
you know like one of those kids it's a
completely different thing whole
different lifestyle man he pulled up in
a nice truck on 10th grade
you know when you're right when he
turned 16 like he pulled up in the truck
he's that kid it means your parents have
their [ __ ] together well they own the
concrete company and or construction i
won't say the names but
you already know who i'm talking about
for from percent and uh
i walk i'm walking through the field the
night and he appears out of like a
bushes and i'm like oh oh what's up
amazing oh what's up dude like thanks
dude
uh later and that was it he walked off
and i'm like
i wonder what it's like to grow up like
that uh-huh like you know what i mean i
remember walking away like wow
that's pretty cool yeah it's pretty cool
this [ __ ] is optional for him yeah this
is not even like you don't have to
walk back scotty gave me his house key
before i went in so i can come back with
a key
and i'm like all right thanks dad i got
it and it was that fast so it was like
you might have actually just got a key
but my dad didn't believe that but he
just let me think that he believed it me
and scotty went back made a can
smoking a bowl in the wind of the full
of the out like we're in the country my
grandma so it's like open your jacket
and cover that wind [ __ ] we're
in a field never try to [ __ ] light a
blunt or some [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
on a can like that it's like this
yeah and you're like frustrating your
fingers burning and you're doing having
someone do this so the bowl doesn't fly
away yeah we're [ __ ] cavemen just
trying to smoke weed and my grandma's
in the field so she looks down go what's
that what is that
see our faces just light up every couple
seconds
so we had a turn they're sharing a pepsi
what the [ __ ] thank you thank you we had
a turn toward the
the country away from my grandma but
that's where the wind's coming so scott
stood like this while i'm like inside of
his chest jacket
that's dedication yeah so that's one of
the times so yes matthew gilbreth
yeah that's one of the links i went to i
lied to my dad
i have a couple stories i never told in
story time that i have some crazy ones
where i have my dad i left my key i've
used that twice
i've used that twice now
the second one was a little crazier but
i'll i'll let that be a story time
because that's insane i don't know how i
haven't talked about it
but yeah i used to do stupid [ __ ] like
because april never april doesn't smoke
weed so i was smoking weed i was always
like it was always like this
annoying issue
so i would always be getting weird like
slow and [ __ ] i mean she doesn't smoke
weed so like
it's just okay it's only annoying to her
gotcha but i remember we'd be like
walking through uh like the grocery
store
and then i hit the bathroom real quick
go outside the dude's waiting out there
good looking oh it's my week yeah
yeah yeah navigating this [ __ ] through
the [ __ ]
i'm i'm in the aisle i know when you're
outside oh yeah
i've done that that type of show a lot
yeah yeah yeah stupid for sure
even now
oh we talked about this before but it's
funny every time i call you in this i
see this guy i'm like oh you're buying
weed because you'll like answer the face
all right i'm just going outside and
meet this guy
thank you sir all right so that was here
thank you sir
the same thing every time thank you sir
my oh you just bought weed yeah
that's so nice you used to have to have
all these relationships with these
college deliveries
they [ __ ] pull up like a goddamn
doordash in [ __ ] 20 minutes and you
like a [ __ ] gentleman thank you sir
yeah before i mean you know it's like
you gotta you gotta hope that you have a
plug and then you gotta hope the [ __ ]
plug has it and then you gotta hope that
they never went through that available
every night they're taking you around
and then now you're sitting there
waiting and all this [ __ ] i was blessed
yeah i never had to do that i was the
guy going i'll be there
yeah yeah yeah
i was the guy
um okay question number one we could do
that hour and a half on this one i feel
like i know i could i had about four
four other wild ones
i got dude it's crazy because i'll
unlock a part of my brain go bro let me
tell you a story i just i was i was
going to say you just realized you had a
story forgotten there yeah because i
forgot richard scott richard scott this
kid helped me with my weed he ended up
like going on a high speed chat i saw
him on the news like a couple years ago
high speed chasing merced and all this
crazy i'm like yo
used to smoke weed with this kid wow now
he's in the [ __ ] news
[ __ ]
he was cool though
um that'd be a story time on to the next
question ready
half baked 760. that's a big ass joint
you got there where do you and marty see
yourself in five years flame oh as marty
hits it
flame
where do you see something five years
marty
man i was reflecting on the way up in
here like it was such a massive [ __ ]
milestone buying this house
that i've only ever looked this far
ahead really like the fact that we're
here now the podcast is going it's the
first time in my life where i am where i
want to be in the present moment
ever so five years from now i don't even
[ __ ] know i honestly haven't even
[ __ ] thought some time and then
you'll have another one you haven't it's
gonna be it's gonna be for the first
time in my life it's like it'll probably
be pretty similar to this just on a
bigger level we'll be partly in real
estate we'll have more [ __ ] going on but
like
up until this point in life if you met
me
my mind was somewhere else i was a dude
who was here but his actual reality was
off in the future somewhere
because i was just always chronically
it's been an issue in my life been in
the state of
trying to get there trying to get there
it's gonna happen getting after it i'm
not there yet always but it's just been
steps up this ladder up until now doing
the house and
having our own [ __ ] and being able to
have it be successful enough to where i
don't have 10 clients anymore
running my life yep that is goals so
five years from now it's just like
completely financially free doing
whatever the [ __ ] we want
and and chilling having time
that's the whole point work your [ __ ]
dick off through your 20s and early 30s
if you have to to be able to like not
have to do that through your later 30s
and 40s and 50s and beyond
exactly it
what about you
that was a perfect answer
or just accomplished it so i don't have
anything yet
um
honestly five years from now
i remember i was 23 and my dad was like
what are you doing all this weed stuff
all online i'm like
if i don't do anything with it by the
time i'm 28 dad i promise i'll go do
something for real
because i always could have had a career
in this and that i'd be managing
something i'm i'm just that type of
brain right
and um
i already told by the time i'm 28 if it
doesn't work out
i'll think of something and i was like
25 like this is working out man i don't
know what to tell you maybe it doesn't
work out by then and then 28 came and i
go oh yeah i forgot about that i'm
[ __ ] in la now yeah so what i see
myself in five years i see myself on
season two of something
on tv netflix that's what i want in five
years
i see myself being on already season two
or something
that's the thing that's what i'm
thinking of
my whole goal in life was to have my
breaking bad
show i had a concept of it like four
years ago
[Music]
not i'm saying the breaking bad i'm
talking about the way it's a story it's
not comedy
but it could be funny if you want it to
be yeah there's funny moments all
throughout it yeah that's it it's
interesting like yeah your finish line
changes
yeah i've i
might
i told like i told marty i had a dream
like
seven months ago that i was walking
through an airport and then like [ __ ] a
mob of people were chasing me and all
these fools were taking pictures and i
started running
i had this dream and i was like oh [ __ ]
and the security's like thomas thomas
get in here and i went
and they're like
come on fool you can't just be walking
through the front like that i'm like
oh and i had like four assists like all
right you're on here today today you're
gonna be doing this this i'm like oh
okay oh and i just started walking i saw
all these people with fan with like
signs i'm like
where the [ __ ] am i at
and then i woke up
i had that dream my dream was never like
you want to be famous i'm like no it's
always
i want to do something that makes fools
stoked as [ __ ] not like hey man thanks
for you know what you mowed the [ __ ] out
of that lawn even though if that was i
was doing i would be the best [ __ ]
lawn guy in the world i would be like
that guy does his [ __ ] job well
because that's like what i think of like
i want to make you go whoa [ __ ]
so that's what we do with the content
like when we stepped it up like damn the
voice full these videos got crazy i know
they're awesome right but
for me it's like
cool videos are great
they're s'more yeah you know so in five
years i want to be on season two
something or
already i always think of you know those
interviews where they're interviewing
somebody
an actor
for their new movie and their poster
board of the new movies right to the
side
that's how i see it i always see it like
that
that's i've always imagined and i see it
happening
i just don't know what it is yet but
that's my thing is to make something to
it's my cult classic i want a cult
classic to look back on when i'm 70 and
go
[ __ ] yeah
there's a whole generation of people out
there that's their favorite [ __ ]
movie
that's what i want you know what i'm
saying like al bundy
you're out bundy forever no matter what
the [ __ ] you do you're out bundy
like you captivated the world for a
period of time
i know exactly that's what i want that's
it not even on the oh you're famous is
more on the
everyone you know has a house like i
know it's crazy
everyone has a house everybody in my
family i bought a house for
hmm
that's cool because if you think about
it if you make 100 mil
you can buy everybody in your family a
decent 500 000 house
and depending on where they live that's
a mansion yeah for sure
great yeah
man once you get like once you hit these
kind of plateaus really goals to me is
just like saving money like i've never
saved money before i've just yeah like
having life insurance you know well the
like if something happens to me my
family's gonna be okay
i want to pay for all my bills and not
check the balance yeah exactly bills go
on autopay thank you that's what i care
about yeah
those are those are goals beyond that
first massive set of goals you set when
you're 19.
i just set goals like three years ago
i've never had that i was just having
fun making videos and people are stoked
yeah it's all i cared about until i went
bro how long can you do that
you have to build something and then i
started like trying to
do because i was running push streets
for [ __ ] six seven years in my
apartment
there was there was no goal set it was
just i was just more close let's do some
more clothes
but yeah five years man so marty you're
there
i just started so we'll see
there that's the question half baked
760. thank you very much marty before
you start what is the time what are we
at
40. doing pretty good all right next one
here we go rex 100 this is one for marty
and i put it in there
because it's all you
when was the first time marty smoked
weed do you remember that day yeah yeah
i do it was with it was with [ __ ]
goofy who we talked about i think two
podcasts it was with [ __ ] goofy
that's when you know you're from [ __ ]
the ghetto this [ __ ] goofy over here
the dude that walked the dude for the
[ __ ] for the ounces yeah
so i i was
goofy
he really that's the only way to
describe him he um
some kid at school had given me some
weed looking back you had probably given
me like maybe a uh a guy gave it yeah
like we were just talking i was like
yeah i never really saw i never smoked
weed and he's like bro give him some
[ __ ] weed in the kid's school yeah in
school and the kid like goes in his bag
and gives me now like probably like a
quarter
quarter zip yeah like a little little
ziploc little bag of weed he just gave
it to me
we were i was probably like 13.
and then uh i brought it to my boy who
ended up doing all that wild extra [ __ ]
and he's like oh yeah this is this is
[ __ ] weird right here yeah
you got little kids you ever smoked [ __ ]
uh-huh yeah yeah cause i was like i was
like always like uh on some straight
edge [ __ ] basically until that point you
know i mean like just super into sports
and all that even beyond that it took me
a while to i didn't even really start
smoking weed so i was like
19. oh wow yeah whoa good [ __ ] good for
you yeah
so yeah but it was it was really kind of
uneventful like i remember kind of
feeling like damn i'm waiting for
something to happen here nothing really
where'd you smoke it we were just like
in the woods or some [ __ ] and it was out
of like a can and then like i the next
time we went to do it we got pulled over
we're on the we were playing if you're
from buffalo you know exactly what i'm
talking about we're playing a delaware
park
biggest basketball court in buffalo main
court in buffalo i used to go out there
with my and one professor [ __ ] all day
long every summer all summer
and we were driving this kid home and he
gave us some weed and [ __ ] goofy
pulled down the wrong way down a one-way
and a cop was coming at us
and just
the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] you boys what are
you doing
how high are you yeah
like
like he had him get out how old was he
if he was driving you're thirsty i told
you we were in the same grade but he was
like [ __ ] 16.
that's why i call him goofy
the guy has a real blurry disability
he was just [ __ ] goofy like he would
just do stupid [ __ ] that's why it was
like that like
he's the one that was in the bathroom
light and all the toilet paper rolls on
fire you're stupid i get that but yeah
he was the same great he was [ __ ]
driving
literally this was the kid
yeah it's an [ __ ] taking his mom's
car
just driving down the street smashing
into mailboxes smashing into garbage
cans
i remember one time he smashes into a
garbage can the [ __ ] gets stuck under
the car and the person's like on their
porch looking out at us
i'm in the back seat he's like broke the
[ __ ] out the kid in the front seat hops
out rips the garbage can out from
underneath throws it gets back in keeps
going the person even say anything
yeah i'm pretty sure they're [ __ ]
yelling at us and [ __ ] how amazing is
that all types of goofy ass stupid [ __ ]
like that but if i saw some kids doing
it but you know what
this is gonna be a story later on your
life just keep going just keep going i'm
not gonna [ __ ] you up go go if you hit
my car then i'm like nah your parents
gotta pay for this i'm sorry yeah we
want some good burgers [ __ ] we scratched
this all summer we were terrorizing the
[ __ ] neighborhood for a couple
summers there
oh you did tell me i dare as a neighbor
you did tell me about that but he was
the one that first put me on the weed
and then some years went by like i was
turning down i was getting uh people
were [ __ ] hitting trying to give me
blunts and [ __ ] constantly but i was on
such a basketball basketball
judged what i ate when i slept who i
hung out with but i did every my whole
365 was revolved around basketball
i never i didn't eat fast food until i
was like 20. damn
like i would never
deviate
it's the only reason why i kept making
the team and [ __ ]
took me that i wasn't like i wasn't
faster than anybody i couldn't jump
higher than anybody i had to go to the
utmost
to be able to make it yeah
so it was i actually ended up getting
kicked off the team over weed
you told me yeah yeah because i i didn't
drink either and like when i was telling
you i transferred to the d3 school for
more playing time
and i just got [ __ ] shit-faced in the
dorm and was so embarrassing and i had a
girlfriend we were both [ __ ] blackout
drunk
straight vodka white boy [ __ ]
and then we went down into buffalo she
got so drunk she passed out i left her
there in the dorm room and we just went
out
i remember this was one of my few white
boy moments where i was just drunk and
could have got beat up out there for
just being [ __ ] stupid on the subway
and [ __ ]
but then we came back to the dorm and
smoked in the dorm and that's how you
got caught yes
so [ __ ] stupid because then i was
like kicked out for that drunk [ __ ] uh
no i didn't i i just crashed and burned
because that happened and they were
still gonna give me another chance even
though i was like i was like lying to
him about it like no no we went
somewhere and there was weed there we
came back we just smelled like weed we
still had the [ __ ] whatever like i
was doing they're like bro
meanwhile i don't even know what really
happened i was [ __ ] hammered all i
know is they knew about the weed i mean
you can't smoke in a dorm without the
whole hallway [ __ ] filling up with
weed and [ __ ]
so anyway i kept giving them [ __ ] i kept
[ __ ] with them
i [ __ ] with the coach i ended up
getting kicked off the team but i wanted
to it almost needed to happen because i
was like
wanting to move so into music so bad i
needed something abrupt to like knock me
off a basketball
that was it
made me do community service all kinds
of [ __ ] then i just [ __ ] stopped
going
so rex 100 that's the first time already
ever smoked weed it turned into him
getting kicked out of college you ran
too [ __ ] yeah it's not just right damn
it's not just me
you see though it connects and something
else connects but oh yeah then this
happened and then by the time
because to me that all happened before i
actually smoked weed
i wasn't smoking weed like
through in any of those incense i got
you
and just for that for i know the people
in the comments this is the longest
joint like it's lasted so long it's the
skinniest so it keeps going out that's
the same one you started at minute
[ __ ] that's like yeah one but it's
gone out a hell of times where we at now
like 50 minutes yeah yeah let's go to
the next question we're doing good man
tar
diff jared
all right i hope so
if you could say anything to someone who
hates their life what would it be
damn
i don't remember screenshotting this
[Music]
wait no i do remember screenshotting
this oh no now i remember why now i
remember why i wanted to talk about this
here we go if you could say anything to
someone who hates their life what would
it be
it could be worse
oh i'm holding back a big [ __ ] rat
right now
here we go here we go
you should start in and i i have i have
some [ __ ] because look at
there's a lot of people that are dead
that wish they could take your place
people like i hate my job i hate this i
don't like my family there's other
places
oh i don't like where i'm at my school
sucks stop going to school
my job sucks get a different job it's
not that easy but it is if someone held
a gun to your ankle you're not going to
the school no more and you can't hang
out with these friends because they're
bad
all good bro because in six months
you're gonna go holy [ __ ] i forgot to
hang out with those people you know how
many times i've done that would go
i remember hung out with him for like a
whole summer every day and i forgot he
existed
that will happen so fast whenever i was
like
20 thinking damn dude i'll never stop
hanging all the i don't even remember i
couldn't even put some of the names in
the faces right now like we are like
brothers like man i'm willing to die for
this [ __ ] he's wanting to die
for me like we are like then you get
their name then it's like yeah all for
[ __ ] nothing
yeah sad
rent does anybody hate in your life i
would recommend watching this latest
episode of rogan with the girl from
north korea
because
not i don't know any not much about
north korea but my understanding is not
too many people escape north korea and
she did
and what she described
was the most horrific [ __ ] i've ever
heard
and
watch understanding what some people
live through even in current day like is
[ __ ] barbaric let alone all the
people that have come before us i try to
express this to my kids all the time
there's still genocides going on right
as we're as i'm smoking joint filming
this talking about problems
well in north korea they have mass
famine so there's bodies stacked
everywhere there's like this girl talked
about every day she she said just as a
fish doesn't notice it water
i grew up not noticing all the bodies
stacked up around me
and
yeah like she's describing the cycle of
you know uh people die and then the rats
eat the people's eyes
and then the children if they can catch
a rat that's like a delicacy so then
they eat the rats
raw sometimes
and then they die and then the rats eat
them and it's the it's the
uh north korean cycle like
every summer some [ __ ] like to catch a
rat to catch a snake is a delicacy
you know to to
to have your ma leave and come back is
like a miracle
there's no mail there's no trains
there's no phones there's no food
the country's surrounded by land mines
and bro you can't get out you can't get
in
there's no lights it's the darkest place
in the world i didn't know all this [ __ ]
i didn't know any of what you did it's
[ __ ] horrible and she's talking about
being desensitized to it you can tell
she's probably gone through 20 years of
therapy or whatever but like
i would consider that if you're living
in america and you're not uh
suffering from like a terminal disease
or you're not actively being like
tortured and kidnapped
things like that really could just try
to zoom out from your own existence and
just understand what people have gone
through before how cold this world can
be boy
we got it so good i tell my kids all the
time we're living better than
99.99999 of people that ever lived yeah
for sure and you to to sit around and be
butthurt is a slap in the face to god
somebody uh comment that quote
to sit around and be butthurt is a slap
in the face to god
marty 2021. that's like a bible verse
bro oh stick that one in the wall we
need that on a shirt to sit around and
be butthurt it's like a slap to the face
to god marty 20 21 prolific and [ __ ]
i loved that bro but for people out
there that are like
all right yeah i understand that but i
can't do anything about that i'm over
here in america and i'm broke and i'm
this i'm that yeah yeah a lot of people
are for sure just work around it and i
know it's it's everybody's been there
and i'm not saying it's easy we did it
no it sucked dick it took me 15 years to
buy a [ __ ] house [ __ ] sucks i
understand i've been hungry as [ __ ]
going to sleep
all that stuff sucks dick i understand
but you got to remember you can always
change your
surroundings you can just change it what
happens if you move to
ohio when you're from l.a and you hate
your life move to ohio for a year
why because when you're 80 and go you've
been ohio actually i lived there for a
year i met this really cool couple i
actually started a business out there i
met these people i have friends in ohio
that's the [ __ ] you need
you know you know what i'm saying
you need that
flip that when you're 90 years old and
you're flipping through every year your
life you don't want it to be while i sat
this job forever i hated
change it
nor do you want it to be like i stopped
where i started
usually to me like most people are born
in small towns and stuff like yeah i i
still don't mind if i stayed him or said
live there and raise a family that's
if that's what you want [ __ ] awesome
you succeeded
there's nothing wrong with staying in
your hometown and living there and
working at the mines or whatever some
old typical [ __ ] whatever they say i'm
gonna work with coal mines like my dad
and his dad and our dad like i get that
that's cool if that's what you like
come do a vacation every year and just
save up your 401k like that's regular
[ __ ] that's cool that's awesome
yeah i envy that on a lot of levels
because you don't have the stresses yeah
and the [ __ ] deadline on the weekend
i go out and jet ski oh man you i would
love that yeah there's no days i could
do that yeah it's impossible that's
goals once every couple months maybe but
then like then why are you working so
hard just you could not be free like no
no i am the boss
there's a there that's the thing that
people don't understand
i tell me when to be done there's a lot
of extra stressors but it's not more
than the stress the everyday stress of
being controlled man we went to sign for
the escrow for this house and we went
into this office i mean people both just
looked at each other like could you
imagine [ __ ] working here oh i hate
that 40 hours a week in here with these
mindless conversations they're having
did you watch this last night yeah my
wife thinks it's really [ __ ] cool oh
i just can't
that's my motivation to get out of there
you did that i did it for so long and i
sat there just thinking about doing [ __ ]
like this the whole time knowing
that i could
yeah knowing that you can is the biggest
thing
the biggest thing ever it's a it comes
from a place of desperation like
yeah sometimes people get [ __ ] done when
you that's your last [ __ ] resort yeah
i get that but like uh
why i always compare it to
um
frog's tail the worst thing in the world
is waste of talent remember he says that
[ __ ]
that is stuck with me since i've heard
it like
that's true holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
true could you ima and i've said it
before how many times i talked about
people like he's real good he just
doesn't understand it and he doesn't
care yeah talent isn't even number one
on the list
at all nope it's like it's like
motivation number four motivation ethics
work work work ethic
talent mm-hmm yeah because i want to
teach you a work i can teach a workhorse
how to do stuff yeah
i can't teach a talented person to be a
workhorse that man if you're feeling bad
about yourself that's something anybody
can dig into is like all right well i'm
the hardest worker in the room
done you're [ __ ] you're never going
to lose
no matter what job it is go large start
making connections focus on who you know
and focus on being the hardest worker
because they're going to notice that
[ __ ] that's the only thing i ever did at
my job is like i wanted everybody to go
damn
or like who did this who did this
that's what i want every [ __ ] time no
matter what i'm doing
it applies to everything
to everything every time the ups guy
comes i try to load him up as fast so he
doesn't bend over and [ __ ] so when he
comes oh that place over there
burbank that dude
my favorite spot to stop like
good
that's what i want to hear so every time
you're like hey i need a pickup i'm
going i'll be there
that's what i want people to be like
[ __ ] yeah he helps me all the time
yeah that and people that work hard
go
yes good [ __ ] cause i do
when i see someone work hard i'm like
[ __ ] yeah good [ __ ] super appreciate it
it is you're in a restaurant you see him
like i can guarantee you that guy hates
everyone he's the only one doing
anything here you can see it too you're
like
oh our waiters [ __ ] hates this job
but he's good to us but you could see
that he hates these people
uh i see it all the time you could tell
who's the hard worker you could tell
who's the
extra mile guy or extra mile girl and
that's the person you have to be every
day even when no one's looking and no
one's around and you're by yourself
that's how you require zero talent
there something that requires zero
talent and will get you everywhere hard
work what a [ __ ] question good [ __ ]
done
hey what's up guys welcome to our
mid-roll ad read this is brought to you
by manscaped if you watch our podcast
you already know about manscape this is
a male grooming tool over 2 million
people have bought this 4 million balls
can't be wrong so if you want to grab
anything for yourself or maybe for your
boyfriend hint [ __ ] use it go to
manscape.com forward slash yolo that's
20 off plus free shipping and good news
for everyone else in the world singapore
australia uk canada south africa there's
now worldwide shipping with manscaped
the newest thing to the manscape lineup
is the performance package 4.0 if you've
thought about buying anything from
manscape now is the time the performance
package 4.0 comes with i know it's
[ __ ] hilarious it comes with ball
toner ball deodorant boxers a travel bag
uh the lawnmower 4.0 itself the nose
trimmer it's the entire package all in
one that's the new performance package
so the features for the 4.0 lawnmower
this is travel safe that means it's not
going to go off in your bag and scare
the [ __ ] out of you it has a light on it
it's waterproof it's wireless chargeable
and you have no reason to be dirty you
have no reason to be nasty and for some
reason for whoever made this is a 9000
rpm in this little machine right here i
don't know why that's some coarse-ass
hair so once again guys go to
manscape.com forward slash yo that's 20
off plus free shipping let's get back to
the video
jonathan dockweiler damn
jonathan doc
what underscores guys hit me with some
underscores
we don't know where these [ __ ] words
start and stop yeah jonathan dockweiler
eight tell us the first time you tried
rosin
the reason i put this in there marty
cause i have a small story i wanted to
tell you guys
rosin have you ever smoked like dabbed
rosin really marty well you have you've
taken dabs of this before right yeah
then you've dabbed derozan was the first
time here during the 100 000 subscriber
then huh i don't know the difference
honestly between rosin and the [ __ ]
this and that and all the [ __ ] you dab
but i've taken
you take a dab with me here yeah of
course then that was the first time you
tried rosin
that sounds fair all right so that was
marty's time and
all right the reason i brought this up
i have a small story what are we at like
55
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah this dude don't make me do i'm
trying to do the [ __ ] math i knew it
i knew that's what you're doing i know
that's the face of
yeah sounds about right i said it before
you said i knew like don't make me do
math
i knew it
that's a quote from marty all right
gonna make me do math out here all right
cool um so the reason i wanted to bring
this up the first time i ever tried
raw's and the first time i heard about
it i need to tell you guys
you ready for this
i
lived in merced at the time
i'm not gonna say who
and i know you watch and yes bro this is
the story i'm gonna tell it because i
love this story about this guy
shout out to you mahomey he's from
washington that's all i'll say and uh
all right i know he's going to see i'm
like
oh [ __ ] this is about me i know it i
love that dude i love that
idea of thinking about somebody like oh
and that's how i think about my uncle
john all the time like
pepper this is the time me and him got
[ __ ] up i know it like it's you're
heading in the direction oh i know what
happened i know what i did
so my friend says hey man i'm going to
bring down some raws and i go what the
[ __ ] is rosin and he starts telling me
it's when you squish weed together and
it all deters and the goo and the bomb
thc drips out and you dab it now we dab
hash i don't dab crushed weed anymore
it's crushed hash hashras that's what
the [ __ ] you see on my snapchat the
gooey white house stuff all that my
homie
that is hashtag and that's that funk
right so
the first time i ever saw rosin the
reason i'm bringing this up because it
made me smile it made me laugh and it
made me think
yo there's people out here with the best
stories ever and i gotta i don't know
how to incorporate other people's
stories because i like telling stories
but only [ __ ] that happens to me because
i could see it
you know what i'm saying i think that
would be a movie and directing [ __ ] i
think that's what that would mean so
that's what i mean all right
i want to direct people's stories so
bronx style [ __ ] yeah it's that bronx
tale [ __ ] so
here we go that's exactly it here we go
my friend says hey i'm coming down do
you know anybody that wants to buy hash
it's 50 a gram and i went oh
50
a gram and back then
i was buying [ __ ] for like 20 to 25 a
gram shatter and i went
50 you're [ __ ] tripping
now my grams are 80 to 120 and i'm
buying an eighth at a time
my [ __ ] my my eighth jars all those
little jars too those are almost three
something
how long do those last like dude i don't
really dab as much as i used to because
i'm not really home all the time
but i can fly through like a gram and
like three dads four dabs five
so if you want to really go hard let's
go quick i'll say it's go quick god damn
it's more than coke
with my like those little jars the
straight over coke prices now it's
ridiculous anyway
my hus so when he told me 50 i'm like
what the [ __ ] back then i'm like i don't
know too many people they're going to
want to buy a 50 gram and merc said
california in 2016
you know so
here we go he says i'm coming down i'm
going to bring some and let me know so i
called a bunch of people i wasn't
selling wheat anymore obviously
or someone just bought it a lot of it
for to sell but i wasn't selling [ __ ]
and i said you know what i'll buy like
four or five grams of smoke and i was
handing in like 400 bucks going
what am i doing to myself and i smoked
it oh my god i love it so it was dj
shorts blue blueberry that was the uh
the strain anyway sorry for taking so
long let's hurry up and get on this
ready go my homie comes over and he says
all right can i park in your garage i
don't want to take it out
in front of the house because it's just
too much and i go okay
yeah in my head i'm like
just take your bag out of your trunk
full it's not that crazy you're not that
crazy drug dealer you're fine right
i didn't understand what he meant
all right i didn't understand what he
really meant
he gets there
i had called some people up to come over
to buy it but hey i have my friends
gonna have a hash if you want to come
over buy some hash and blah blah so i
had like
four people come over and like cash them
out a couple hundred bucks here so i was
trying to help him out on his drive to
la he was selling all this this hatch
all this rosin that i just found out was
real
and uh
here we go he pulls into my garage i
take my car he pulls in we open his
trunk
and i go
uh where's it at
and he looks at me goes
all right dog
let me show you something i already look
all right let me show you something i
remember like all right
he pops up a
screwdriver i'm like what are you doing
full where's the hash
and he starts undoing the bolts rivets
from his truck
and i'm like
how much hash do you have
this full took apart all the panels from
his car
and there was hash in
the entire car
packaged up like coke bricks but in
packaged sleeves of rosin with the
flavors on it bricks i'm talking
stacks of paint parchment before it was
jars like parchment papers
bam bam one brick
and every [ __ ] panel of the car and
he was like i'm only gonna do one side
what's flavor all right cool it's on
this side he had the flavor separated so
he knew like okay well in arizona this
full wanted this boom it's a front panel
and he just pops it off and the girl it
was [ __ ] amazing and i remember he
opened it i looked at he goes i know
where i'm like i [ __ ] love you
so much more right now he goes bro i
told you i got some hash on me i'm
trying to get rid of it and i'm like yo
you got like 200 pounds of ash in your
car what if you got hit
what if you got an accident
that's all i kept thinking
all the panels of the car
it's like yeah there's over there and
the flavors are over there and i got
like a mixed spot spot right here in the
trunk so if it's like smaller smaller uh
ounces
he can just bust it down if people want
pounds he's like it's over there it's
over there
i'm looking i'm like you're not kidding
oh my god and that is the first day i
ever smoked rosin
and that's why i put that question in
this house the first ever rob to fall
for a car
i ain't never robbed anybody in my life
i never [ __ ] will why would you move
around with that much goddamn rosin get
rid of it god damn he got rid of it man
it's a [ __ ] risk
he's that guy
he's that guy
and i think that's the last question is
it nah
one more
next
chill will o3 best advice for teens
getting out of high school i put this in
there because i think this is
a topic that is never gonna die because
every year there's a new [ __ ] class
and you can revert back to what we're
gonna say
marty what's your advice to somebody
getting out of high school guy or girl
i remember first of all when i got out
of high school just having this moment
of realization like
oh [ __ ]
like
this is what i just i looked at
everything differently because i started
looking at adults as like oh i'm
becoming an adult
oh my god i can't have this life
like i just felt
terrified like at mediocrity
as a 19 year old seven actually 17 year
old getting out of high school looking
around it would get that's i remember i
made a decision in life right then it
was aimed at music at that point but i
was like i knew in my own mind
can't have this i got to go all in i i
remember thinking i got a bet on someone
in a million [ __ ] that's what it's gonna
take but i'm okay with that i
i didn't understand kids that didn't
have a mentality like that that didn't
wake up and have something they were
getting after my best advice for
somebody to get out of high school
is to first of all don't get yourself
wrapped up and we've bitched about this
a lot do not get yourself wrapped up in
a bunch of unnecessary debt or ruin your
credit protect that [ __ ] at all costs
give yourself time to breathe too i
didn't know what i wanted to do in life
till i was 25. i went and wasted all
this money in college all for nothing
basically you gotta
find out who you're gonna be and
understand that
this is a whole new chapter now your
whole your life is just starting
and you don't even know what it's like
yet so you gotta go out and experience
some life before you really can expect
yourself to know because everybody's
trying to force it down your throat go
to college you know do what you got to
still figure out who you are at that
point
you're you're coming out of being a
little kid and experiencing adulthood
for the first time so
my best advice would be don't waste your
20s
follow your gut
try to explore what your passions are
and [ __ ] go for it use your 20s use
that time to go for it swing for the
fences if your parents let you still
live with them and pay your bills take
advantage of that [ __ ]
as much as you possibly can
save up your money
and
you know figure out where your finish
line is but like thomas said you might
not even know what the finish line looks
like and that's okay too you just gotta
work with what's in front of you
and just make sure you keep making steps
forward we didn't podcasting didn't
exist when we graduated high school and
looked around and we're like [ __ ] this
is unacceptable
but we set goals and then eventually you
know you might not even your finish line
may not even exist at this point but by
the time you get there
it's something you didn't even know when
you started that's the crazy [ __ ] about
it yeah
but
it's always the you got to set those
simple goals what is the simplest thing
like when i watch the secret the movie
the secret completely changed my life
because i was like
did we talk about this or no oh i'm
sorry i'm thinking the movie the secret
window with johnny depp i'm like no no
you're watching a bad horror movie
about the law of attraction
no i was just like you need to focus on
the feelings you need to focus on what
it feels like to wake up and not feel
and
not to not feel broke but what would it
feel like to wake up feeling comfortable
and relaxed and
like everything's taken care of what
does that feel like and focus on that
feeling i don't know yet yeah though
that's what matters to me it's not like
the specifics
of oh i got a bentley and i got a
mansion and i got this many sneakers
it's it's more like my family's situated
i'm not stressed out at my [ __ ] together
like that's the goals
but watch the secret that changed my
life the price literally saved my life
100 watching that movie
never seen it
it was it's a book
it's probably kind of like cheesy and
corny now but the whole gist of it
really saved my life which was
the law of attraction
that's real though yeah it's like
gravity like whether you understand that
it's working or not it's working and
it's just not to say that things aren't
deliberate and random in the world but
you do have some
control over what's going on in your
life the way i see the law of attraction
is
for all the people out there that there
a lot of people will watch like gamers
and [ __ ] so think of it like this you
know when you're playing a video game
and it's like
pick up scroll for later
mission you go nah it's okay
that pickup scroll [ __ ]
is the law of attraction like it is like
no no no that's gonna come back to play
later you need to [ __ ] think about
this think about it motivate yourself
think about and then who knows later on
in the game your life it's like wait
i used to do this in high school who
would have known i'd be making a [ __ ]
million dollars a year doing this [ __ ]
as a business
and then he's like do you think about it
i could probably do this as a [ __ ]
job as you're doing it in high school
the scroll from the beginning of the
game is the same thing like no no i'm
gonna [ __ ] do this talk about it
manifesting law of attraction is real
as [ __ ] i just try to put it in a game
sense as you would see like no no those
little pieces at the beginning will make
sense later they're not there for
nothing
there's a reason you took
metal shop like you know what i mean
there's always something
it's like a video game like when people
think so this is a simulation and if it
is
turn on that
secret passage for later i mean do it
talk about it now so it's building that
up while you get there
i know it's like with john like oh
someone someone's gonna pay me one day
to do this [ __ ] yeah and then [ __ ]
happen
it's not just saying speak it it'll
happen just talk about it think it
imagine yourself doing that [ __ ] yeah
the visualization and and then but then
it also is every day after that you got
to move forward towards that
this is a lifestyle that that's that's
the other component that people miss out
of the movie the secret it's not just
about the visualizing and the wishing
that's how it starts that's where it's
literally how it starts because it
starts in the mind everything that
has ever come to be started in someone's
mind
you know aside from the even the earth i
don't [ __ ] know that could have
started from some mind that we can't
even understand i don't [ __ ] know but
to plant to plant it and to know that
okay there is some finish line that i'm
headed towards if you're a kid that
feels like you hate your life or if
you're just getting out of high school
and not knowing what the [ __ ] to do you
got people pulling you in all different
directions
i would focus on that what do i want to
feel like
[ __ ] all this other [ __ ] like how do i
want to feel what would that even feel i
remember the first time i like
visualized like driving in a nice car
remember like sitting there what it
would feel like to like driving a nice
car my mind was like a bentley
and like there's the like you could
really sit there and in your mind make
that [ __ ] happen you can feel it
everything is real it's like
exhilarating do me a favor when you're
going to sleep later
try your best to feel everything and see
it in your brain
and once you can like do start doing
that
it i don't know why but your brain's so
much stronger than i think people
understand
like i can start thinking of things and
a couple weeks later i'm like
hey
i heard i was just thinking about this
the other day
looking for it you see yeah you start
seeing little pathogens to it kind of
already happened in life it's weird
right there's so many it's like a
[ __ ] movie sometimes it truly is how
many times you guys sit there and start
thinking of a song 40 minutes later it's
like on the radio i'm like that's a
old-ass song i haven't heard that [ __ ]
in the radio and years i was just
singing in my head
i feel like your brain starts to look
for things and when you look for things
you meet the person you should have met
you [ __ ] went to the party you should
have went i don't want to go through
these questions i mean look how it came
together exactly it's like it's
okay you guys are meant to do this but
you were being a piece of [ __ ] for all
these years and you missed the [ __ ]
link
but what about oh i went to that party i
did talk to that person i did do oh [ __ ]
i met him oh i met her oh we did this oh
i did that oh me and my wife we met
randomly bumped into each other why well
i was late doing something and i
wouldn't have missed it if i wasn't
doing this i was thinking of daydreaming
about this thing i want to do and i
bumped into
the world it is butterfly effect the
world is all that [ __ ] that's how it
this is how it happens it's not only
that but there is some of that at play
you know there's been so many times in
my life where i can attribute that's how
i think now it's just the way my brain
works is that
i'm kind of like taking my brain doesn't
really go on autopilot i just try to be
really deliberate with the things that
i'm thinking about because i know that
there's power in it in what i'm placing
my like
real focus on and my real like
intentions on how you go out and deal
with the world when nobody's looking
even like leaving a room better than you
get into a type of [ __ ] when no one's
looking that's your overall intention
that's what's kind of like reverberating
out and back and like if you're somebody
that your inner conversations real nasty
and negative you've talking all this
crazy [ __ ] about people con that's not
real healthy for well
you're losing yeah well
it's a little bit just more of like a a
clean kind of
i had to rewire my brain i really really
did but i liked it because i wanted
religion i wanted something to call real
and i knew everything that was in front
of me when i was getting out of high
school right at this age was pivotal in
my life i knew it was all [ __ ]
especially because i went to a private
school for
the last three years of high school and
like i said
i wasn't like the other kids in school
i was the kid that when they did their
ceremonies i was the only kid in the
whole school that stayed seated
when they'd go do their little set like
there was like an auditorium they'd go
do their the sacrament [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] bread and all that
the whole school got i was the only one
that sat and didn't do it out of respect
for their [ __ ] i don't believe in this
i was like 16. they're looking at me
crazy i transferred to this
oh you [ __ ] monster
i transferred to the school for
basketball i'm coming into this school
with these catholics this man this
full-grown father just said out of
respect i [ __ ] on their religion
because i don't believe in this [ __ ] i
didn't i just think it's funny it was
probably respect but
that's how i felt [ __ ] with you it would
be it would have been i can't take this
yeah i'm gonna yeah i i couldn't do it i
understand why you said that and what
you mean
it's just really [ __ ] funny bro the
whole school looked at me like i was
yeah like demon oh that's the white
rapper kid that doesn't [ __ ] believe
in god
i was so different yeah now that i think
about it oh my god
oh no yeah i think marty thank you when
they did their prayers and [ __ ] before
class [ __ ] dribbling i'm just sitting
there yeah just air dribble riders
i know i was like yeah they i was the
only one who didn't grow up going to
church i was i already
did i had to like and earlier this guy
said
don't be butt hurt oh it's a slap in the
face to god yeah that's real though i
know it's just funny like that's the
same episode man i wish i could go bad i
wish i could go back now i would imagine
these rants a 14 year old version of me
ranting about north korea this [ __ ]
ranting while he's like all right now
i'm across you okay go yeah
and they're like yeah that's what you're
here for all right yeah you're here just
play basketball just play basketball all
right don't we don't want your
shut the [ __ ] up marty
martin lawrence o'neil yeah yeah yeah
that's another big one out there yeah
that's [ __ ] martin lawrence marlars
hamburger
um damn
we could just do an entire show on your
family questions okay
can you go back to the notes
thank you for your fan questions that
was
dope as usual podcast on instagram okay
holy [ __ ] we're we're what time is it an
hour or something yeah about hour 15.
hour and a half we're being extra
mindful on this episode
upload time is a beast and yeah
that
is friday night so here we go
i'm gonna bring something up right now
that i really i as soon as i started
talking about it to my friends half the
[ __ ] i scream at my homies i'm like
i need to do this on stage to stand up
because sometimes sometimes i make
myself laugh and i look around like
nobody no no i gotta write this down and
that's why my notes are just
fast all right here we go
did you guys hear the news
that they caught you know in you know
what hour and a half let me be mindful
i'm not gonna give you this [ __ ]
backstory of argentina and nazis i think
we've already gone over that i know a
little but i'm not gonna go through it
that's my brain wants to go no no no
let him know what's going on in the
world and then get to the small
here we go
apparently there's a hundred year old
man that's getting going to trial
because they find they found out he is a
real identity he was a [ __ ] nazi
sergeant or some [ __ ] he was a nazi
he's getting charged with 3 500 deaths
right now 3 500 murders of jewish
um
people
there it is a hundred year old [ __ ]
nazis getting tried on trial
and
here we go
he's getting on trial he's 100 years old
i say so this is why i brought this up
because i started talking about
what i would do and i was thinking
no matter what
if that was me and i'm the guard and i'd
be like this i'ma slap the [ __ ] out of
this old man like he's a hundred i'ma
slap the [ __ ] out of this old man when
no one's looking i'm gonna punch him
right in the [ __ ] face and then as
i'm holding his hair like hey hey you
[ __ ] i'm gonna make him watch
sucking seinfeld over and over the whole
[ __ ] the whole see the whole series
like
hello look see this you didn't get his
parents [ __ ] look what happened
you see this i was thinking like this
all went through my brain as i'm telling
it to my friend he's taking a dab like
that
like yeah you see that you wanted to
stop that [ __ ] you wanted to stop
festivus [ __ ] yeah festivus
what is that going on with that you
wanted to stop that [ __ ] as i'm just
popping look at his turtleneck look at
him look at his [ __ ] hair huh you
like it's curly as [ __ ]
that's it
i said that all to my friend
and i thought yo write this [ __ ] down
full because that
is stupid but it makes me laugh now
imagine
the guards at the prison just popping
this old man in the mouth i know it's
elder abuse i know it's super mean i
would take a shot at him yeah it's fine
for sure
but oh
the 30 year old version of you was a
piece of [ __ ]
at least one and like
there's about
300 000 people right now that would be
like yeah
and then the other the other ones would
be
nazi sympathizers
yeah they're all getting booted in the
balls too
bro
i don't know there's about
nine million dead people right now that
would be like yo thanks
we appreciate it
my whole side of the other side of my
family's jewish never met him but i
gotta hit him with the [ __ ] kramer
just leave the red light on him
from the hot chicken place i [ __ ]
love seinfeld so much
but we wouldn't have seinfeld all right
that's pretty much what i was getting to
like you would you want to take this
away and then it just cut see this is
the kind of [ __ ] i want to do on t on a
show and as the guy just like
tripping and it goes into what he would
do and it comes back he's just a nurse
applying the guy's iv
yeah he's cuffed to the bed like oh
sorry i just imagined me beating the
[ __ ] out of this old man going all
clockwork orange peeling his eyes open
making him watch and [ __ ] i watched that
when i was five my mom showed me yeah it
[ __ ] me up the milk
the rape scene
[ __ ] me up i didn't understand why the
cops were beating his ass they were his
friends
[Music]
it was all [ __ ] it was weird why not
for a five-year-old my mom's wild but i
remember
um
watching it just tripping clockwork and
then the end where he's
[Music]
weird [ __ ] weirdo [ __ ] anyway great
movie
here we go that's the nazi thing 100
year old nazi getting tried because he
finally got caught for his true identity
good [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you got to live like an extra
60 years you [ __ ] i hope they were worth
it you they shouldn't easily [ __ ] she's
just back they should send them back and
throw them into attack throw all the
handmade's tail on them yeah just throw
them into a town like bro i'm sorry but
the new law
with this new this new law the way our
bank account set up now is you get to
get beat to death they get to circle
around you and they're all holding
stones and that's just that
i don't even bat an eye at it
it's [ __ ] up that whole era you know
less than a hundred years ago era
yeah [ __ ] pretty [ __ ] pretty [ __ ]
recent
damn
so that was a nazi thing
that's where my brain went with that
make him watch seinfeld while i pop him
in the mouth every couple minutes
like this though when you hit a kid on
the mountain they cut
they go
that's what i do to him as he's like
like yeah you know what's funny huh you
know what's laughed [ __ ] you know
what's funny they're hilarious
could you imagine the nazis just like
try not to laugh at seinfeld or larry
david
she's like blasphemous to him
i gotta stop
here we go it's friday the 13th all
right
it is friday the 13th
and i didn't think about that until we
were
writing this the episode out and i'm
like oh [ __ ]
damn it's friday the 13th
have you got any ghost stories that's
how i'm gonna end this i got one i mean
i'm not trying to go too far into i'll
go into it in a full story time or
something but
apparently the first house my mom and
dad had when we were babies was haunted
and the ghost hates my dad that's all i
know my dad talks about it and my mom
talks about it and they don't like each
other back then and they had the exact
identical stories like
to the [ __ ] t identical stories so
apparently on yosemite parkwaymer said
i used to live there
my mom said i always used to talk to
something in the bathroom
i was like a little baby like trying to
chill with something and she's like
is there a [ __ ] ghost in here this
baby sees and apparently my sister used
to be talking in the room because she
said there was like yeah like i'm
hanging out like there's nobody [ __ ]
there and my dad
that's the reason they moved my dad told
me the story and my mom told the story
the same way apparently my dad was about
to take a shower and the old school 90s
mexican guy waits
the dumbbells with the [ __ ] biggest
plate ever with the little spinners on
the side with a screwy metal
my dad had those
he said he put it in front of the door
because the door never closed
when we were walking around because we
would just pop it open and he's like i
don't want you guys always [ __ ]
trying to come in the shower your little
kids like this is my i'm putting the
weight there so you guys i can have a
take a shower that you guys [ __ ] with
me basically is what he said
and he said he heard it like
open and move he's like what the [ __ ]
and he said he looked out and nobody was
there and then he said something just
scratched his ass on the back held the
heart and he just popped out butt-ass
naked ran out the house waited for my
mom to come back
and then my mom
told us that she was in the bathroom
like the curtains moved all [ __ ] big
out of nowhere just
like into the air and mom's like what
the [ __ ] was that and then my dad same
their their stories matched up
identically so i went oh so there was a
[ __ ] ghost in yosemite parkway jesus
my grandma even told me about the same
thing like you mean your haunted ass
house like oh
it's true
that's the only reason i bring that up
is because that's something that
happened once okay so [ __ ] petty why
not do this
how would you be like mow the lawn
[ __ ] why don't you [ __ ] dust
do something real rent free living
[ __ ]
that's possess some lady down the street
to clean my [ __ ] house
[ __ ]
ghosts are petty they're passive
aggressive too that's the name of our
stand in the stand the first stand i've
ever do ghosts are [ __ ] petty
seriously
what are you opening the cupboards yeah
you open the cupboard
arrange my [ __ ] yeah
yeah we're over it [ __ ] think about it
do the dishwasher if you're going to be
doing this type of show you're making
vases
like in ghost
make uh you know let me just stop let me
just stop
because i was about to get ridiculous
about [ __ ] that's not real
here we go i'm maturing all right here
we go like you know i just pulled the
happy gilmore where he's about to throw
his [ __ ] putter
wait wait maybe this is a new reserved
version of happy gilmore
[Laughter]
that's that was me right now
i just played the whole scene i love
that movie here we go
ghost story i will tell you my one ghost
story
aside from that other one no there's
more
i'll just
leave it at this
my friend ryan
his house is haunted
we all know ryan from all the story
times ryan ethan's house is [ __ ]
haunted
i think houses get haunted when there's
bad [ __ ] energy and bad people around
and they attract some [ __ ] that they
brought and they just carry with them i
think tweakers have demons around them
all the time
i think really bad drunks and alcoholics
and
evil [ __ ] just bring that vibes
when you move into apartment it was some
old tweakers house there's it's still
there that energy st like i don't know
why i feel like drugs like open up this
dimension of like letting [ __ ] in i
don't know what it is but i feel it for
sure i hate people's [ __ ] old videos
i hate that [ __ ] so much and it's real
people you guys are [ __ ] high i am
high first off but second don't believe
in it then [ __ ] you get your back
scratched up if you don't yeah if you
don't feel that [ __ ] when you go into a
used apartment you know oh yeah
like i wanted a certain grows like
no i told i talked about that one and
right after it got [ __ ] robbed at
gunpoint like something bad's here
um
so ryan and ethan's house we all know
it's haunted they talk about it all the
time
the first time i slept over there
there's like 12 of us we always pass out
in the living room because ryan's mommy
says let's get [ __ ] up there that's
where
we started doing hello lines and that's
where all the mushroom where the first
time i took mushrooms on the cul-de-sac
this is it so uh
i'm in the back room
no i'm in the living room there's like
four dudes
there's two beds in the back room two
dudes on the floor ryan's room uh
ethan's room and like their homies on
the floor like
it's the pass out time house you guys
know exactly what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about you're probably there right now
watching this together trying to fall
asleep
am i right all right
trying to hide the last bowls to your
everyone falls asleep so you don't have
to waste all your weed
yeah it's that time i'm in the living
room by my [ __ ] self first time
i've ever slept over there and i'm like
it's okay i know ryan's mom makes
the most kool-aid i've ever seen in my
life there was not not five pictures of
kool-aid at all times
and these crazy-ass dollar store cookies
she would have this tub full of them so
i in the middle of now i'm like oh yeah
all [ __ ] up cold ass you know what i
mean like i'll stay right here in the
middle of the night it's like [ __ ] yeah
i'm gonna get these cookies and kool-aid
i'm laying there and as i'm laying there
i just feel like someone is standing
over me
and i'm trying to fall asleep
and i just like
blankets to my eyes
i could feel someone like oh someone's
about to grab me i could feel it and
like clothe you know when you close your
eyes and you know something's there
you're like oh oh god don't put your
blanket over your head because when you
come back you know something's going to
be there it's a movie i'm sitting there
i'm like oh my god oh my god oh my god i
turned my shoulder toward the couch and
i felt it worse and i'm like no i'm
getting up right now and i went and i
laid right next to four other people on
the ground i don't give a [ __ ] with no
cushions no nothing because i laid on
the couch because i was like ah i'm
gonna sleep on the floor and be right
next to all you fools nope i crawled in
like when [ __ ] puppies
all chill go to sleep that's what i do
i'm like oh [ __ ] this i will sleep
between all this [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] first not ever slept at ryan's
here's the ghost story ryan and them
always describe it as a dude in black
shirt i'm like you guys are [ __ ] high
we're doing cocaine
i think you guys are high but i believe
in that [ __ ]
i am playing nfl blitz
playing nfl blitz with six five steve
i've talked about
we're in ryan's room i'm looking at the
tv we're playing nfl blitz steve's right
no no sorry i'm not with steve sam
i thought steve i thought it was steve
sam the asian guy with long hair you
played football with him sam
me playing nfl blitz it's all we're
doing playing blitz
and that's it everyone's in the garage
drinking and i'm like ah [ __ ] it you
know once you go to a place so many
times you're like
i'm not missing on anything i'm gonna go
play blitz for a while come back out
we're drinking smoking people come over
people leave
it's the hangout house so i'm like [ __ ]
up with sam [ __ ] yeah we're playing
blitz and i'm doing this one you know
playing like oh [ __ ] and i don't hear a
door open or nothing but ryan's door to
his room's open but on the other side of
ryan's room is the front door it's
pretty loud and the dogs so i'm like
i didn't hear anybody come in i didn't
hear the garage door come in but i just
see some tall ass dude
right here the door's right here i'm so
sore
so i couldn't even point i went to the
personal trainer sorry real quick i went
to a personal trainer and i can barely
move my [ __ ] arms that's why they're
not fully extended everybody respects it
everybody respects your life oh god
i just try to point out
if you see me doing this
anyway i see the door's right here but
like five feet that way i'm playing
blitz and the only person over six two
in our group is six five ryan's like six
foot
that's pretty much it and steve six five
has a like a flat top
so i'm playing blitz and i see the guy
like right there but it's you know what
i mean i'm not looking away from the
game i'm playing i'm like yo what's up
steve
6'5 what up
hey [ __ ] you what's up steve
you know what i mean you're home he's
like what up hold up
what's up what's up man one of those
like i'm playing blitz sam's playing
blitz
all right all right [ __ ] you oh what's
up what's up three times ago all right
[ __ ] you then uh what's up steve
and then the fool just does that walks
off and as i walk off i look and i just
see
the hand leaving the doorway
and the back of the shirt i don't really
i think it's like
it's not like he's wearing jeans i
didn't i can't tell you the pants let's
just say that i just remember the
movement as he's walking away and i
looked real quick like
is this full what's going on you didn't
say hi i mean [ __ ] you steve like i was
at your house last night [ __ ] uh you
know it's friendly like
eat a dick i was just talking [ __ ] so as
he walked away i'm like as well really
walking away and as i look it's just
like the back of the shirt in the hand
out the doorway i'm like
[ __ ] you steve and i think nothing of it
i just keep playing playing blitz
playing blitz playing blitz me and sam
are playing
about three minutes later remember
the the i thought it was steve went to
the left and left went to the left of my
doorway my vision and went and went out
that's the end of the house the only way
to get out of the house or in the front
which is to the right i'm explaining
this because it makes
makes sense
not a sound effect
all right not a sound effect god damn
paranormal
we just heard at least three different
people screaming right now
uh all right
all right
cool
well when we move the set we're
definitely going to need some sound
protection because that was [ __ ] loud
here we go
damn about three minutes later after i'm
playing blitz and steve didn't say hi to
me at all
steve walks in the [ __ ] door
the front door comes straight to the
room what's up guys i'm like
sup steve like what
like [ __ ] you fool i said hi to your ass
three times you didn't say [ __ ] goes i
just got here
i'm like oh it must have been some other
dude that came through the garage that i
haven't met or i didn't know was here
you know because i knew who was here i'm
like oh i'll drink i was gonna go the
[ __ ] play
and he must have came through the garage
i'm like okay it's somebody else
i'm like
you just got here
you wearing a black shirt and steve was
wearing a black shirt too i'm like
fool's talking [ __ ] i go in the garage i
have to play the game smoking a
cigarette i look around i'm like
has anybody else comes not just us like
nobody else has been here
no
yo ryan i saw the [ __ ] ghost i
finally went yo ryan i saw the ghost
full he goes what are you talking about
let me hear because i always told him
yeah right [ __ ] no it's haunted
it's [ __ ] haunted that's why he
always had everybody sleeping the rooms
together and i was like we're good bro
i'll just be on the couch but when i
felt that was
and i went in so haunted he can't have a
sleepover without he doesn't he doesn't
he no he'll sleep through this door open
with like wait actively haunted every
night
bro
often it's to the point where every time
i go to the bathroom
i would leave the door open with my foot
propping it open because of the goddamn
ghost no it's the vibe
it's i only saw that thing once
it's the feeling
of like
and all it did was well ryan's mom and
her and her boyfriend they were like on
drugs and [ __ ] were they bad alcoholics
at the time the energy there was like
fights and beer and fights and bad [ __ ]
it was that house
so i feel like something was just like
ugh something bad anyway i tell them
ryan
i told my no i saw it and i'm telling
steve
if you're telling me you just [ __ ]
got i'm just explaining it
and i'm like he had a black shirt on and
ryan goes
i [ __ ] told you he has a black shirt
on and short black hair go
yep kind of looks like steve's like yeah
it looks like light skin nasty it was
just like a white dude black shirt
short hair like a buzz cut
and i [ __ ] saw the back of him moving
like because i i could see it physically
see something but i was playing games
like that like i told you like what's up
full if i would have just looked it
wouldn't have been steve but i didn't
look that's why i was like stevie
[ __ ] with me because i can't tell you
100 if i'm right or wrong i'd take his
word for it and then i'm explaining like
dude i saw he's like bro i just walked
in the door steve lives
five house
four houses away and across the street
he's there every day
so i thought oh maybe he went home and
came back that's why are you sure you're
not [ __ ] with me so it turns out i
finally [ __ ] saw what everybody's
been seeing ethan was in the bathroom
and something [ __ ] knocked his ass to
the ground when he was in the shower
um
ryan got scratched on his neck
and that was
it as far as i remember
scary stuff but the one time that's why
i started keeping the door propped open
when i went to the bathroom
is because i was washing my hands one
time all coke the [ __ ] out and i know
you're like it was the coke
no i've done coke before and the the
shower curtain started
moving like a like wind
and i just did this one
i looked up and looked at the window for
the bathroom it was shut and i went oh
i walked out power walked from malcolm
in the middle like
back to the garage
oh [ __ ] but i didn't know him that well
yet so i didn't go like you got i just
[ __ ] this house
but it was a regular house but we all
knew like
it's creepy out here it's scary that was
ryan's house and it went away like after
like four years like it didn't we didn't
like
feel it like that no more we were there
every [ __ ] day every weekend all
night all day
and during school days we'd go there get
[ __ ] up and go home because that was
the house you're allowed to get [ __ ]
up at
my dealer's story time
john the one that disappeared was their
older brother
so after high school i started hanging
out with john too and that's when i got
that connect because he was the guy of
our town like that's your brother fool
holy [ __ ] like he's the fullest outbacks
and he's only got the mercedes like 19.
he's that cool
so
that's the paranormal one from ryan's i
have other ones but that's the one that
like
holy [ __ ] i see what you guys saw and i
thought you guys were [ __ ] with me
but yeah i know it was legit dude i
finally saw what they were everyone else
has saw i was the newest guy
ryan uh and joe and anthony had already
been hanging out with like two weeks and
then they introduced me to ryan
so i was the last one out of all like 15
dudes at chill that was the last and the
newest guy so they were like the sandlot
don't look down
that's what they did there's a ghost
are you trying to [ __ ] with me [ __ ] you
but the scary thing when i was sleeping
that got me like maybe there is a ghost
and the curtain moving i'm like
maybe it was the ac
but i'm still getting out of here and
that hallway from the from the bathroom
left
straight to the [ __ ] garage door was
like the
like as soon as you get past it you know
you're okay it's like being in open
water in the dark like oh i don't know
what's happening sometimes i would close
my eyes and just [ __ ] power walk
through the hallway jesus christ ah that
houseman
she still lives there
yeah it's crazy it's all remodeled and
nice and new and it's cool
but if it really is a ghost and that's
the afterlife like sometimes like oh
sorry your afterlife glitched out now
you're just roaming around now you're
stuck you [ __ ] with these drug edit kids
all right you gotta just [ __ ] let me
scratch one sure every three months i
get to scratch somebody i'll be back
i'll i'll be waiting yeah you ever seen
frighteners with michael j fox
i don't know i don't think so go watch
it guys that's what the afterlife sounds
like i did see a movie where these two
there's these two kids that are like
living they go they're like homeless and
they're living house to house without
the people knowing that they're like
living in their attic they're just like
squatting without you knowing they're
there type of thing it's pretty
disgusting
yeah but maybe that's what was going on
it was a [ __ ] tweaker it was just
like hiding from you know
and [ __ ]
i thought that at um
which house
i thought that at my my nice house
uh what did i talk about this on the
podcast
there was something in my house
my nice house in merced
maybe i'll wait for story time
but i waited until we drove off and
we're a few blocks away
and then i started telling rosie what
i've been seeing in the house because i
didn't want to scare her
i think somebody was living in my house
my addict
[Music]
i think there was and i was too afraid
to like find out
did you just call your attic an addict
oh yeah there was an addict in my attic
i liked it i mixed yeah i did there
might have been a drug addict in my
addict
so uh
one day i went to the top and i'm like
wait wait what do you mean
what do you call it no no i wasn't gonna
say nothing i'm
not you i don't call it an addict i call
it an attic
but oh no i know i realize that [ __ ] my
words i get that okay okay i thought
you're going to say like no no these
ghosts we call it this no i was gonna i
was gonna see if you wanted to keep
going with this because i'm interested
to know how you
there was a [ __ ] dirty handprints on
the part to get into the into the top
like
the days after i heard some [ __ ] i went
okay
i'm very observant i see everything and
i look and went oh walk past it there's
a [ __ ] handprint there now oh
[ __ ] and when i was alone i would hear
[ __ ] move up there
and it always freaked me the [ __ ] out i
never wanted to tell rosie but there was
a few spots in my hallway where i felt
like i felt something
like someone staring at me i could feel
this [ __ ] but it was a tall ass if you
see the pictures our house was huge it
was one of those like why is the [ __ ]
ceiling so high how do you clean it yeah
one of those houses so i feel like if
someone wanted to live up there they
could the first thing i did when we got
here i had somebody look up there it was
me oh was you
okay
it was you then
i just remember going look in the back
make sure the bag's good
the one warehouse we were gonna get
before this was definitely infested with
tweakers
that warehouse was scared we even turned
the lights off when the thing went
like somebody shot this building with
bullets just beams of light coming in
like well there's vampires man stand in
the [ __ ] middle and you're fine there
were so many cracks we would have never
been able to film you know that yeah
i'm so happy we didn't get that spot
dick
whoa yeah
um
anyway i'll stop with that because
there's a huge long story
about the house i'll just i'll do it
another time but
the ghost at ryan's [ __ ] me up that
[ __ ] scared me because i thought oh i
know what i know what you guys see now
because i saw it identically what the
[ __ ] you tell me hmm
that's creepy everything it goes across
people seeing the same thing yeah they
told me when i moved there yeah he's got
a black shirt on tall ass dude that's
they always say tall ass dude i don't
like that
[Music]
my friend mundo his mom is
a medium
and i'm like okay iran's a medium she's
a real medium you know those sylvia
brown people you're like ah she's fake
she's a real medium i didn't think that
[ __ ] was real no i've talked to a real
medium oh she's real
she's [ __ ]
legit
because i asked her about some [ __ ]
because some weird [ __ ] was going on i
asked her
and she described something so first off
the boy with you is some of them like
yeah what'd you just say [ __ ] i didn't
say this to anybody but one of my homies
died and i was like there's a you know
when someone i was like oh man i wish i
could have [ __ ] told him this [ __ ]
yeah
and then she's like so he wants to let
you know that this this this it's okay
he knows you mean it although i'm like
what did you just say and she described
him i go oh my [ __ ] god i didn't
mention this online
i haven't talked about this ever
what the [ __ ] did you just say as as i
sat down she's like
your energy is amazing and i love you
already and i go thank you she's like
your girlfriend as she rosie walked
she's like
she's awesome she's glowing
all right
let's get into this and she goes so
before we start the boy with you wants
me to let me know i go
the boy with me
what are you talking about she described
him
she described his face i know it's the
second she said something a certain
thing went what'd you just say
and she goes he wants to let you know
that you know you wanted to say this and
i'm like
what the [ __ ] nice to meet you
holy [ __ ] let's start talking and then
she she blew my mind but that's my
homies mom and she's legit she has like
books and [ __ ] like that i won't say her
name but she has books and she's a radio
show and she's legit legit lady dude i
had an experience like that once it
really changed my life where
in buffalo when i was like 19 my
girlfriend and i went to one because she
had some like heavy duty really deep
baggage like she was working with or
their dad died and stuff
so yeah like i remember she sat down
with the medium and
whatever the medium started saying to
her like
she just like unraveled this like like
you're saying it was like tear it wasn't
even about her dad i remember like it
just
really really just got to her core
immediately and then very very similar
also when it was like my turn to talk to
the person it was like
i remember it gave me a lot of
confidence because the
way they put it was like
it was like they could tell like about
me and they were like
they said you you have uh like golden
footsteps kind of laid out in front of
you you're gonna go you're gonna go to
california you're gonna do you're gonna
meet somebody there they're going to
remind you of yourself you're they like
they weren't so much like predicting the
future and [ __ ] i mean i know i kind of
like in that instance they were a little
bit
but it was also just like affirmations
about you as a person and what's like
how you're saying like
they're just going to start saying some
[ __ ] that's
you has nothing to do with anything you
weren't asking about you weren't
thinking about i definitely experienced
that too
but it gave me a lot of confidence
because that's what i took from it you
know
it was [ __ ] she gave me some good news
and i pat on the back and said keep
going keep doing what you're doing
cool yeah [ __ ]
i think about it though i think about it
often actually some of the stuff they
said i'm like god damn that [ __ ] is
coming true even now and you know yeah
i've never went anywhere like that i was
just taking dabs in my homies
his mom was in town i was like she's
gonna come over and go like okay i want
to ask her about something
and then that led into that so it was
random so i never went yeah and i don't
even believe in it
but that's real i just know that what
they this person was able to tap into
something that they were able to like
pull [ __ ] about that like you're saying
you would never know
right before i met rosie
her and her friends went to one and she
told her this whole long story about her
life about rosie's life
and it was directly described exactly me
it was weird
she told me about when we met she's like
so crazy i went to a [ __ ]
a psychic
like as a girl saying we're always
hanging out we decided let's go to one
and she described exactly when and
everything the person she'd meet all
this [ __ ] that we ended up getting
married and all this crazy [ __ ] it was
like
heavy visions of you guys pushing trees
get out of here
yo are my la i tell you about my when
you look at my last name as a crest yeah
it's a lion against the tree
we discovered that remember never yeah i
was like your goddamn logo your family
crest is dead
touching a tree standing straight up
[ __ ] you
no way i had no idea i had no [ __ ]
clue my family crest when you look back
on your name on where your name came
from
our crest is literally like all this
cool [ __ ] and a tree looks like our logo
kind of tree
with a lion
pushing it like touching it with two
hands crazy rosie's is just a tree the
same tree almost as our logo and it's a
tree with all these designs next to it
like a detailed the leafs all that yeah
i know [ __ ] trippy what the [ __ ] man
fate for real how crazy yeah
um
what are we at 132
150. no way really yeah
did all right yeah we did all right hey
we're getting good points basically
we're getting good hey
we oh man we don't even need bullet
points at this point yeah sometimes i
just do it to remind myself hey talk
about that nazi [ __ ] but oh yeah that's
right i'm talking about this nazi yeah
that's good we're professional that
hurts so bad to do that right in my arm
i [ __ ] forgot
um
yo
this was the catch-up episode this is
the hangout episode the
smoke away with your friends episode
because it's about to be guest on guest
on guest that we wanted to hang out the
solo episodes is our chance to say hey
what's up guys this is what we've been
doing did you watch that [ __ ] oh my god
because we're covered from last episode
too last episode was such a roller
coaster and like i've never seen so much
emotion and like a live chat to have
everybody tapped into that while you're
describing all that was like a special
moment in podcasting period
that doesn't happen often
yeah while watching it i started
remembering what we talked about i just
remember all of it but i was like
spacing out or [ __ ] something
and uh it was good though man i got a i
go oh i probably didn't talk about i
feel so much better
holy [ __ ] talking about it out loud oh
my god i don't feel so [ __ ] up from it
it's so weird to say that
it just works like that i didn't know
that it worked like that but it really
[ __ ] helped i don't feel like is
about it
odd yeah good though never goes away
it's like uh
i don't know if i came up with this
thought myself or if i heard it but it's
kind of like when you deal with the
death of somebody really close to you
it's like uh it's the the volume is
always on but it's just how loud is it
on
sometimes the volume's quieter but then
you know it's still on still in the
background never really goes away
that's how it is well my dumb ass was
gonna say it's like a series finale but
you can always replay it in your head
i'm an [ __ ]
she was all prolific and mine's like
it's like a show that ends and you know
like you can watch it again
jesus christ um
i think yeah that's it guys we just want
to catch up hang out i don't even
remember everything we talked about damn
these
thanks
you make time fly by sometimes
um
yeah that's everything man with guests
coming up 100 000 subscribers
appreciate you guys we got the plaque we
actually got the plaque so
on next to the 500k is our next goal
500k we don't really
do anything else on the channel we
should start like
putting up some vlogs or like say
because we're going to have sean
o'malley mm-hmm what if we're just like
do a vlog with him and get [ __ ] up
and post that
yeah right yeah i mean like yeah hey
that's what we did also this week that'd
be cool i'm man we're kind of getting to
the point where we can start doing [ __ ]
like that now
as far as scheduling it's working stuff
yeah dude the schedule's working i did
three videos on dope jewel channel one
week and that caught me up yeah so now
i'm like okay next week i already have
next week's video done this week
and the next week after that is already
gonna be done next week oh i'm never
lagging now like right now i just posted
a video yesterday i'm already almost
done with the next edit and the next
video i film is tuesday so i'll be too
caught up and then i have another one on
filming friday
about a month ago you caught up yeah i
finally caught up to myself
i mean obviously we've never done this
before so we just had to make all we had
to get
so much done to be able to get in front
of everything yeah somewhere really work
all right we're going to work for two
weeks straight no straight to catch up
enough to be two days ahead
because if we have three more people
we'd be on schedule but we're only two
people instead of
five and
sadly we lost deanna's gone she went to
another job so
now it's
all marty yeah marty it's all marty
doing everything but it worked like
we're talking about timing and stuff it
worked out though because of my clients
i know but it's yeah it's all good
workhorse as marty that's i would
suggest i would rather have all my
attention on this even if it's the
thumbnails and the clips i would rather
have my touch on it than being spread
thin with 10 clients yeah like you said
like marty said recently he used to have
so many clients it was his whole life
was like oh what do you need what do you
need what do you need what do you need
uh what time is it [ __ ] yes
but now it's like okay we're done
working you got your own thing doing
you're doing your own thing you're doing
now you're down to what two clients well
i got obviously the podcast and then you
know dopisiola is a whole separate
client that's a whole other client yeah
but then from as far as my comics that i
work with it went from ten to three
being broken
rogan theo and sickler primarily
nice which is sick they're yeah it's
it's so because you just had so much to
do it was impossible they all have
podcasts they all book dates they're all
getting back on the road
but i would i just you know i want my
time uh spent primarily on this that was
the goal from the top this was world
we're just doing what we said we're
going to hopefully be able to do yeah
it's actually working but we'll be able
to put up more content on the channel
the more time we have i would love that
i would love to be able to post another
video on the channel right it'd be so
cool like we were talking about like
with stereo you know that whole
situation got [ __ ] but we're still
yes wanting to do something like that
yeah
so i was about to comment some [ __ ] i
was like you know what maybe
contractually i shouldn't
yeah we'll figure that out
yeah
the other day i did i went i'm going to
erase this entire comment yeah there's
been plenty of comments i've went back
and
that's
yeah you know what maybe in the contract
because i can't do this and then you
guys are like yeah yeah yeah yeah
10 episodes ago we were talking about
you know i'll show up at your [ __ ]
door where's our money we're still going
through it all right but i won't say
with who it's not stereo all right it's
not we actually like them
but we might actually be going back on
steroids yeah but uh
yeah we're still dealing with this [ __ ]
it's all right
it's okay take it as a loss for now [ __ ]
uh it's okay guys
yes uh thank you so much new sponsor
today to see shout out to tushy
not tushy.com it's hello tushy all right
let me say that again it's
hellotushy.com
hellotushi.com
we found out that tushy.com is porn
well actually brandon one of our
employees is that how we found that out
well i was on the face i was on the zoom
call with tushy talking about the
sponsorship and then brandon's like yeah
yeah
don't look up tushy.com he's like i did
it at work
we're in the whole facetime meeting with
the owner and the ceo and all that [ __ ]
and she's like oh yeah yeah no we've had
horror stories like so
hellotushy.com hello okay not just us oh
my god i was like yeah i was at work man
and i pulled up the wrong side like oh
[ __ ] could you imagine no i mean like oh
yeah
how do you explain that [ __ ] you look
like a pervert
so yes thank you to our new uh sponsor
hello
the bidet spray water directly into your
ass
yeah
we're going to get that on the
soundboard
like joe pesci and [ __ ] home alone
yes
yes
that's what i was thinking of that's the
reference i get good
um
yeah shout out to the new sponsor
[ __ ] awesome man uh
thank you guys very much honestly
bro when the pandemic was going on there
was no toilet paper i guarantee you
everyone that had the tissue was like oh
it's fine
we're good i'm not running to the store
like savages yeah look at you savage's
dry [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yo bro it's so crazy like
there's a reason why rich people in the
movies have them because it's a luxury
because it's that much cleaner it's what
you're supposed to be doing yeah
we could do a whole episode on this
i didn't know that it's like oh no it's
like 90 cleaner
oh you mean
uh washing with water versus just
smearing smearing it with paper cleaner
and paper dust in the air because you
get cheap toilet paper i did that all
the time
oh this [ __ ] sucks it's hell of dust
you know exactly what i'm saying that
[ __ ] winter snow uh-huh
yo let's paint a picture yeah let's stop
all right let's stop
thank you guys so much for watching um
thank you so much for hanging out with
us next week goblin eric khan episode
comes out
thank you guys so much for watching and
then we have brian callan
freeway crosstalk we haven't even
brought on the booking agent yet yeah
did you hear that freeway
yeah you did it it's my invisalign guys
i have a speech impediment now i can
barely say lawnmower 4.0
yeah
since we got man skate sponsorship i
[ __ ] up 62 times lawnmower 4.0 oh i
got it again he doesn't you can't that's
literally the first time you've ever
ever got it a lawnmower he always is
like one more 4.0 yes i'm a little kid
that can't say the odds llama 4.4 point
it's because the invisalign has gave me
a speech impediment you have to like
back into it you got to go it's not the
3.0 it's the 4.0 that's the loophole i
got it's the lawnmower but not the 3.0
it's the 4.0
and i gotta chop it up yeah you hate
this chop that's why the manscaped edge
like this
dick
it's cuz i can't say 4.0
but i got it i haven't been wearing my
invisalign um as much
i've been wearing it all day actually
and i've been wearing it at night only
man don't fall off the invisalign
because i won't i'm just waiting for my
new guards because
somebody wants to lag on my new mouth
guards i won't say where i go but
hey man hurry up
i've had the same mouthguard for like a
month and a half come on it's supposed
to be a weekly thing
it's gonna be [ __ ] up pandemic i
understand but
yeah let's just stop
spray water up your ass shave your dick
it's pretty much what we're saying all
right dick and fart jokes oh bro come on
look at our sponsors
bring them
we're [ __ ] ready also get buff on it
um
all right why are you got anything else
to say no it's the last time we're gonna
be talking directly to the fans for a
couple weeks
so thank you guys man that last episode
felt so great it made me just proud to
be a part of this and like i just really
[ __ ] right about it and our fans are
the coolest yeah that's what i mean
really
it says martin
you put your name as martin not marty on
stuff and the government did that [ __ ]
oh okay i was like i don't know martin's
computer what the [ __ ] yeah no that's my
apple the government does that [ __ ] get
out of here
i just looked at who's mark oh yeah yeah
uh see we gotta stop thank you guys so
much for two hours and six minutes
yeah somewhere around there
not too bad
thank you guys so much for watching this
has been another episode of the dope as
usual podcast this is episode 28
episode 28 all right oh
real podcast it's really happening thank
you guys so much for hanging out we just
passed
5 million views on youtube thank you
guys so [ __ ] much we just hit 1.3
it's more than that now
it's and it's really more like 6.5 on
youtube if you count the clips channel
that's how i like to put it up oh all
right there we go 6.5
but for spotify and apple downloads
we're at 1.5 what's good
million downloads
just apple on spotify not not everything
else 50 other audio ones holy [ __ ]
that's yeah
that's pretty cool yeah that's pretty
[ __ ] cool for all the new fans that
didn't come here from the dopaziola [ __ ]
welcome
thank you guys for being here and just
hanging out with us for the fans that
have been here through the doppelganger
stuff thank you for seeing the
transition and seeing like
evolution the evolution it's not just
this pack from this company and we just
get demonetized and then youtube did
monetize us and deletes us and we try to
do this the right way and it [ __ ]
worked
so thank you guys for being here and
seeing it happen and
[ __ ] crazy being a part of making it
happen yes from there you go most of all
for you guys are the reason it works
it's the reason it makes it happen every
time you guys share some [ __ ] our
twitter our instagram we have tiktok now
we need to start using more but dope as
usual on podcasts on take top we
you guys support everything we [ __ ]
do everything so thank you so much we're
about to have phone cases sick ass phone
cases coming out we're gonna have new
shirts with a puff print we haven't
we got stuff coming out so thank you
guys so much for watching thank you for
hanging out thank you for supporting
marty and i this has been the dope as
usual podcast let's not let's uh if not
i'll keep going i will keep going and in
15 minutes ago so thank you guys for
double usual podcast
i just felt it happening yeah guys thank
you so much if you're in the car please
be safe be safe be careful driving we
got more
we get them every week
watching the podcast on christmas i got
another one like two days ago please be
[ __ ] careful i know it's a
reoccurring thing it's almost repetitive
at this point just
be [ __ ] safe if you're at home hang
out with your friends or you're by
yourself have a good ass night if it's a
start in your day i hope your day is
good if you're going into work don't
worry maybe you won't do it forever and
if you do do forever [ __ ] it
it's okay
thank you guys so much for watching
until next time i'm dopaziola have a
dope as day
whoa
the most precise episode ever man
not too bad i'm i'm [ __ ] high
way higher than i thought i'd be
martin
it's my brother's name is when i saw him
like what the [ __ ]
i always forget that because i always
i don't know because i never think of
your name as martin
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]
perfect